welcome to the reinforcement learning
jumpstart series I'm your host Phil
Taber if you don't know me I'm a
physicist and former semiconductor
engineer turned machine learning
practitioner in this series of tutorials
you're gonna learn everything you need
to know to get started with
reinforcement learning you don't need
any prior exposure all you really need
is some basic familiarity with Python as
far as requirements for this course they
are pretty light you will need the
opening eye gym because we're gonna be
taking advantage of that rather
extensively you'll also need the atari
extension for that so we can play games
like breakout space invaders you'll also
need the box 2d extension so we can do
the lunar lander environment and beyond
that you will need the tensor flow
library as well as pi torch and I'm
gonna have tutorials in both tensorflow
and PI torch with a bit of a stronger
emphasis on tensor flow I'm gonna teach
a course in somewhat of a top-down
fashion meaning we're gonna get to the
really important and exciting new stuff
like you learning and policy gradient
methods first after that we'll kind of
back up and take a look at things like
sarsa double Q learning and we even get
into how to make your own reinforcement
learning environments when we code up
our own grid world and then solve it
with regular Q learning if you missed
something in the code don't worry I keep
all this code on my github which I will
link in the pinned comment down below
I'll also link the relevant time stamps
for all the material in case you want to
jump around because maybe some topics
interest you more or you want to get
some additional background information
from the explainer videos questions
comments leave them down below I will
address all of them let's get to it in
this video you're gonna learn everything
you need to know to implement Q learning
from scratch you don't need any prior
exposure to Q learning you don't even
really need much familiarity with
reinforcement learning you get
everything you need in this video if
you're new here I'm Phil and I'm here to
help you get started with machine
learning I upload three videos a week so
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out imagine you've just gotten the
recognition you deserve in the form of
offers for a machine learning
engineering position from Google
Facebook and Amazon all three are
offering you a boatload of money and
your dreams a big bowling are
interrupted by the realization that's
starting salary
is just well the starting salary you've
got friends in each of the three
companies so you reach out to find out
about the promotion schedules with each
Facebook offer is $250,000 to start with
a 10% raise after three years but with a
40% probability that you'll quit Google
Offers $200,000 to start with the 20%
raise after three years but with only a
25% probability that you'll quit amazon
offers 350,000 to start with a 5% raise
after five years with a 60% chance that
you'll end up washing out so what should
you take all three of our big money but
feature raises are far from certain this
is the sort of problem reinforcement
learning is designed to solve
how can an agent maximize long-term
rewards and environments with
uncertainties q-learning
is a powerful solution because it lets
agents learn from the environment in
real time and quickly learn novel
strategies from mastering the task at
hand cue learning works by mapping pairs
of states and actions to the future
rewards the agent expects to receive it
decides which actions to take based on a
strategy called epsilon greedy action
selection basically the agent spends
some time taking random actions to
explore the environment and the
remainder of the time selecting actions
with the highest known expected feature
rewards epsilon refers to the fraction
of the time the agent spends exploring
and it's a model hyper parameter between
zero and one you can gradually decrease
epsilon over time to some finite value
so that your agent eventually converges
on a mostly greedy strategy you probably
don't want to set epsilon at zero
exactly since it's important to always
be testing the agents model of the
environment
after selecting and taking some action
the agent gets its reward from the
environment
what sets Q learning apart from many
reinforcement learning algorithms is it
performs its learning operation after
each time step instead of at the end of
each episode as is the case with policy
gradient methods at this point it's
important to make a distinction
traditional Q learning works by
literally keeping a table of state and
action pairs if you're implementing this
in Python you could use a dictionary
with state in action tuples as keys the
only feasible and environments the
limited number of discrete states and
actions here the agent doesn't need to
keep track of its history since it can
just update the table in place as it
plays to the game the way the agent
updates its memories by taking the
difference in expected returns between
the actions it took with the action that
had the highest possible future returns
that sends up biasing the agent's
estimates over time towards the actions
that end up producing the best possible
outcomes when we're dealing with
environments that have a huge number of
states or state space that is continuous
then we really can't use a table in that
case we have to use deep neural networks
to take these observations of the
environment and turn them into discrete
outputs that correspond to the value of
each action this is called deep cue
learning the reason we have to use
neural networks is that there are
universal function approximate errs it
turns out the deep neural Nets can
approximate any continuous function
which is precisely what we have the
relationship between States actions and
feature returns is a function that the
agent wants to learn so can maximize its
future rewards deep Q learning agents
have a memory of the states they saw the
actions they took and the rewards they
received during each learning step the
agent samples a subset of this memory to
feed these States through its neural
network and compute the values of the
actions that took just like with a
regular Q learning the agent also
computes the values for the maximal
actions and uses the difference between
the two as its lost function to update
the weights of the neural network so
let's talk implementation in practice we
end up with two deep neural networks one
network called the evaluation network is
to evaluate the current state and see
which action to take and another network
called the target network that is used
to calculate the value of maximal
actions during the learning step the
reasoning for why you need two networks
is a little complicated but basically it
boils down to eliminating bias and the
estimates of the values of the actions
the weight of the target network are
periodically updated with the weights of
the evaluation network so that the
estimates of the maximal actions could
get more accurate over time if you're
dealing with an environment that gives
pixel images just like in the Atari
library from the open a I tune then you
will need to use a condom
neural network to perform feature
extraction on the images the output from
the convolutional network is flattened
and then fed into a dense neural network
to approximately the values of each
action for your agent if the environment
has movement as most do then you have an
additional problem to solve if you take
a look at this image can you tell which
way the ball or panel is moving it's
pretty much impossible for you to get a
sense of motion from just a single image
and this limitation applies to the deep
Q learning agent as well this means
you'll need a way of stacking frames to
give the agent a sense of motion so to
be clear this means that the
convolutional neural network takes in
the batch of stacked images as input
rather than a single image choosing an
action is reasonably straightforward
generate a random number and if it's
less than the epsilon parameter pick an
action at random if it's greater than
the agent's epsilon then feed a set of
stacked frames through the evaluation
network to get the values for all the
actions in the current state find the
maximal action and take it once you get
the new state back from the environment
add it to the end of your stack frames
and store the stack frames actions and
rewards in the agent's memory then
perform the learning operation by
sampling the agent's memory it's really
important to get a non sequential random
sampling of the memory so that you avoid
getting trapped in one little corner of
parameter space as long as you keep
track of the state transitions actions
and rewards in the same way this should
be pretty safe feed their random batch
of data through the evaluation and
target networks and the compute the loss
function to perform your loss
minimization step for the neural network
that's really all there is to deep Q
learning a couple neural networks a
memory to keep track of states and lots
of GPU horsepower to handle the training
speaking of which of course you need to
pick a framework preferably one lets you
use a GPU for the learning PI torch and
tensorflow
are both great choices and both support
model checkpointing this would be
critical if you have other stuff to do
and can't dedicate a day or so for model
training that's it for now make sure to
share the video if you found it
helpful and subscribe so you don't miss
any future reinforcement learning
content I'll see you in the next video
in this tutorial you're gonna learn how
to use deep cue learning to teach an
agent to play a breakout in the
tensorflow framework you don't need to
know anything about deep cue learning
you don't even need to know anything
about tensorflow you just have to follow
along let's get started if you're new to
the channel I'm Phil a physicist and
former semiconductor engineer turned
machine learning practitioner here at
machine learning with Phil we do deep
reinforcement learning and artificial
intelligence tutorials three times a
week so if you know that kind of thing
hit that subscribe button let's get to
the video so if you're not familiar with
deep cue learning the basic idea is that
the agent uses a convolutional neural
network to turn these set of images from
the game into a set of feature vectors
those are fed into a fully connected
layer to determine the value of each of
the actions given some set of states in
this case the set of states is just
going to be a stack of frames because we
want the agent to have a sense of motion
so as we go along we'll be stacking up
frames passing them to our network and
asking the network hey what is the value
of either of the actions move left move
right or fire a ball we're gonna slow
this into two classes one of which will
house the deep Q networks and the other
will house the agent and in the asian
class we're gonna have other stuff that
we'll get to later let's go ahead and
start with our imports will need OS to
handle model saving will need numpy to
handle some basic random functions and
of course tensorflow
to build our agent so we'll start with
our deep Q Network the initializer is
pretty straightforward we're gonna take
the learning rate number of actions the
name of the network that is important
because we're gonna have two networks
one to select an action one to tell us
the value of an action on that later the
number of dimensions in the first fully
connected layer the input dimensions of
our environment so for the Atari Jim
sorry the Atari library of the opening I
Jim all of the images have 210 by 160
resolution and we're gonna pass in a set
of frames to give the agent a sense of
motion we're gonna pass in four frames
in particular so it's gonna be 210 by
default 210 160 by 4 we're gonna do some
cropping later on
we'll get to that in a minute we also
need a directory to save our model so
the next thing we need is the tensorflow
session this is what instantiates
everything into the graph and each
network wants to have its own then we'll
call the build Network function to add
everything to the graph once you've
added everything to the graph you have
to initialize it very important
tensorflow will complain if you don't do
that so best to do that now and the way
you do that is by calling the TF global
variables initializer function other
thing we need is a way of saving our
models as we go along and this is
critical because this deep queue Network
takes forever to Train I let it train
for about 10 hours and it averages a
score of 2 to 3 points per set of
whatever number of lies it gets so it's
gonna have to train for quite some time
so we're gonna want to be able to save
it as we go along because we have other
stuff to do
right
and of course you want a way of saving
your checkpoint files next thing we need
is a way of keeping track of the
parameters for each particular network
and you do that like this so what this
will do is tell tensorflow that we want
to keep track of all of the trainable
variables for the network that
corresponds to whatever the name of this
particular network is we use this later
when we copy one network to another next
let's build our network so we're gonna
encase everything in a scope that is
based on the age of the network's name
we're gonna have placeholder variables
that tell us the inputs to our model
we're gonna want to input the stack of
images from the Atari game we want to
input the actions that the agent took as
well as the target value for the cue
network I'll get to that in a minute
and this convention of naming in naming
placeholders and layers you're gonna see
repeated throughout the tensorflow
library the reason is that it it makes
debugging easier if you get an error it
will tell you the variable or layer that
caused the error very handy so you can
probably tell by the shape here that we
are going to do a one hot encoding of
the actions and the same thing for the
cue target so the convention of using
none as the first parameter the shape
allows you to train a batch of stuff and
that's important because in virtually
every deep learning application you want
to pass in a batch of information right
in this case we're gonna be passing in
batches of stacked frames so we'll get
to that in a moment the next thing we
have to do is start to build our scroll
down a little bit and start building our
convolutional neural network so let's
start building our layers
the first one will have 32 filters
kernel size of 8x8 strides a 4 and a
name of conf 1 the other thing we need
is an initializer now we are going to
use the initializer that the deepmind
team used in their paper reason is that
we want to learn from the experts and
may as well do what they do if it's
going to make our life significantly
easier and that's going to be variance
scaling initializer the scale of two and
then we want to activate that with a rel
u function
sorry it's calmed one activated so our
next layer is pretty similar it'll take
the activated output of the first layer
as input that'll take 64 filters if
you're not familiar with what a filter
is you can check out my video on
convolutional neural networks a kernel
size of in this case 4x4 strides of -
name of com2 and the we can go ahead and
copy that initializer why not
so that is our second convolutional
layer we're gonna do something similar
for the third of course and that will
take komp2 activated 128 filters to by
sorry i 3x3 kernel good grief
astride of 1 and a name of conf 3 and
the same initializer and of course we
want to activate it as well so the next
step is once we have the outputs of our
convolutional neural network we want to
flatten all them and pass them through a
dense network to get our Q values or the
values of each state action pair let's
do that now
and that's where our
fc-1 dinners come in and we need a value
activation and oops we will do the same
initializer for the dense layer so next
up we need to determine the Q values Q
and Q learning just refers to the value
of a state action pair it's just the
nomenclature and this will be the output
of our neural network and of course we
want to have one output for each action
and this gets the same initializer now
we're not activating that yet we want to
just get the linear values these are the
linear activation of the output of our
network so the next thing we need is the
actual value of Q for each action and
remember actions is a placeholder and
next thing we need for every neural
network is a loss function so we just
want to have the squared difference
between the Q value that the network
outputs and something called acute
target the Q target let's get to that
now so the the way Q learning works is
that at each time step it's a form of
temporal difference learning so every
time step it learns and it says hey I
took some action what was the maximal
action I could have taken and then it
takes the delta between whatever action
it took and the maximal action and uses
that to update the the the neural
network as its lost function so our
training operation
it's just a form of gradient descent
atom optimizer in this case this
alerting rate and you want to minimize
that loss function let's give this more
room so that is almost it so that is our
network so the next thing we need is a
way of saving files right and sape and
loading them as well the reason we want
this is as we said these models take a
notoriously long time to Train and so we
may want to start and stop as we go
along and what this will do is it will
look in the checkpoint file and load up
the graph from that file and save it and
load it into the graph of the current
session
and we're gonna say frequently as we
train something like every 10 games and
all this function does is it takes the
current session and opposite to a file
pretty handy so that is our deep Q
Network what this does again is it takes
a batch of images from the environment
in this case breakout passes it through
convolutional neural network to do the
feature selection and it passes it
through a fully connected layer to
determine the value of each given action
and then uses the the maximum value of
the next action to determine its loss
function and perform training on that
network network via backpropagation next
up we need an agent that includes
everything else all of the learning all
the memories all that good stuff so it's
gonna take something called alpha that
is the learning rate gamma that's a
discount factor a hyper parameter of our
model the memory size number of actions
an epsilon that determines how often it
takes a random action a batch size a
parameter that tells us how often we
want to replace our target Network set
of input dims we use the same as before
210 160 by for one moment my cat is
whining we need the directory to save
the queue next network and we will need
a directory to save the cute evaluation
and what this as I said will have two
networks one that tells us the action to
take the other one that tells us the
value of that action so let's go ahead
and start our initializer so when we
take random actions we will need to know
the action space which is just the set
of all possible actions
and we need to know the number of
actions we need our discount factor
gamma this tells the agent how much it
wants to discount future rewards the
memory size which tells us how many
transitions to store a memory of course
our epsilon and Epsilon greedy and then
we need our network to tell the agent
the value of the next action so we'll
pass in the alpha learning rate number
of actions input dims the name and the
checkpoint directory
okay so now we have our two networks the
next thing we need is a memory so cue
learning works by saving the state
action reward and new state transitions
in its memory we're also going to save
the terminal flags that tell the agent
whether or not the game is done that'll
go into the calculation of our reward
when we do the learning function so we
need a state memory just a numpy array
of zeros we shape mem size and input
dims and so this will save a set of four
transitions of four frames stacked four
frames by number of memories
and we also need an action memory and
this will handle the one this will store
the one hot encoding of our actions that
is just one-dimensional this will just
store the agent's memory other rewards
and then we need the terminal memory so
this just saves the memory of the done
flex and to save RAM will say that one
is into eight and you know what we can
do the same thing with the actions and
this is important because we're gonna be
saving 25,000 or so transitions on my PC
this consumes about 47 gigabytes 48
gigabytes of RAM I have 96 so it fits if
you have less you're gonna need a
significantly smaller memory size just
something to keep in mind so next thing
we need to do is to store those
transitions in memory and this is of
course pretty stateful straightforward
so we need the old state the action the
reward the new state let's just call
that state underscore and a terminal
flag so that I'll just be an integer 0
or 1 so the agent has some fixed memory
signs we want to fill up to that memory
and then when we exceed it we just want
to go back to the beginning and start
overriding it so the index is just gonna
be mem Kontor which is the something I
forgot let's put that up here
so that will be the counter that keeps
track of the number of memories that it
has stored so for our actions we need to
do the one hot encoding and when we pass
in the action it'll just be an integer
so making an array of zeros and said in
the index of the action you took to one
is a one hot encoding and of course you
want to increment the memory counter so
the next thing we need is a way of
choosing actions so dpq learning relies
on what is called Epsilon greedy so
epsilon is a parameter that tells it how
often to choose a random action we're
gonna DK epsilon over time the agent
will start out acting and purely
randomly for many many hundreds of games
and eventually the random factor will
start decreasing over time and the agent
will take more and more greedy actions
the greedy action is choosing the action
that has the highest value of the next
state so this takes the state as input
you need a random number from the numpy
random number generator and then will
select an action at random from the
agent's action space if we are going to
take a greedy action then we need to
actually find out what our next highest
leap
highest valued action is so we need to
use our evaluation network to run the
cute eval dot Q values tensor using a
feed dict of the sorry the I can't talk
and type at the same time of the current
state has the Q evaluation network input
and then of course if you want the
maximum action you just need numpy to
arc Max of actions and when you're done
just return the action so now we come to
the meat of the problem we have to
handle the learning so learning has many
parts to it the basic idea is first
thing we're gonna do is check to see if
you want to update the value of our
target network and if it's time to do
that we're gonna go ahead and do that
the next thing we're gonna do is select
a batch of random memories the most
important thing here is that these
memories are non sequential if you
choose sequential memories and the agent
will get trapped in some little nook and
cranny a parameter space and what you'll
get is oscillations and performance over
time to actually have robust learning
you want to select different transitions
over the entirety of the memory so
that's how you handle memory batching
and sampling and then you have to
calculate the value of the current
action as well as the next maximum
action and then you plug that into the
bellman equation for the Q learning
algorithm and run your update function
on your loss so let's go ahead and do
that
so first thing we want to do is see if
it's time to replace our network target
network if it is go ahead and do that
and we'll write the update graph
function momentarily next thing we want
to do is find out where our memory ends
less than mm size else this will allow
us to randomly sample a subset of the
memory and this will give us a random
choice in the range maximum of size
batch size so next we need our state
batches these are just sorry these are
just the MM state transitions we will
need the actions we took and remember we
store these as a one hot encoding so we
need to go back to a we need to go back
to a integer encoding so we need to
handle that and the simplest way to do
that is just to do a numpy dot operation
to just multiply two vectors together
so next we need to calculate the values
of the current set of states as well as
the set of next States sorry sorry the Q
eval and the next so this will take
these set of next states these transit
the transitions
the next thing we want to do is copy the
Q eval Network because we want the loss
for all of the non optimal actions to be
zero next thing we need to do is
calculate the value of Q target so for
all of these states in the batch for the
actions we actually took Plus this
quantity here so the maximum value of
the next state multiplied by this
quantity terminal batch so the reason is
that if we if the next state is the end
of the episode you just want to have the
reward whereas if it is not a terminal
state the next state then you want to
actually take into account the
discounted future rewards so next we
need to feed all of this through our
neural network
through our training operation
we need the actions which is the action
we actually took and we also need the
target values which we just calculated
so the next thing we need to do is to
handle the prospect of decreasing
epsilon over time remember epsilon is
the random factor that tells the agent
how often to take a random action the
goal of learning is to eventually take
the best possible actions so you want to
decrease that epsilon over time so we
handle that by allowing the agent to
play some number of moves randomly so
we'll say a hundred thousand moves
randomly and we want to dictate some
minimum value because you never wanted
to do purely greedy actions because you
never know if your estimates are off so
you always want to be exploring to make
sure your estimates are not off and you
can decrease epsilon over time any
number of ways you can do it linearly
that's what deepmind did you can use
square roots you can use any number of
things I'm just gonna do this we're
gonna multiply it by some fraction of
one a bunch of nines that'll give you a
really slow decrease of epsilon over
time so the agent takes a lot of random
actions and does a lot of exploration
sorry I flipped my sign there thought
that didn't look right so yeah if it
tries to drop below 0.01 we're gonna go
ahead and set it there okay so that is
the learning function next up we have to
handle the functions to save the models
and this will just call the save check
point function for the respective
networks
next function we need is a way of
updating our graphs so what we want to
do is we want to copy the evaluation
Network to the target Network and this
is actually a little bit tricky so what
you want are the target parameters this
is why we saved them earlier and you
want to perform a copy operation on them
now the reason this is non-trivial is
because you have to pass in a session
and the decision of which session to use
is non-trivial so you have to use the
session for the values that you're
trying to copy from not copy to so if
you had Q next you would get an error
which took me a little bit to figure out
so that is our agent class next up we
have to code a a main function so of
course we have to start again with our
imports I'm going to import gin and we
want to import a network
we will also need numpy to handle the
reshaping of the observation we're gonna
truncate it to make the workload on the
knurl the GPU a little bit lower so
important um pi as NP if you want to
save the the games you can actually use
that with you can do that with the
wrappers so I won't put that in here but
I will put that in my github version so
you can just do a git pull on this and
you will have the way of saving the
games so first thing we have to do is
pre process our observations and the
reason you want to do this is because
you don't need all of the image we don't
need the score and we also don't need
color we just need one channel so I've
already figured it out if you take row
30 onward and all the columns then you
will get a good image and you want to
reshape it like so the next thing you
have to handle is a way of stacking the
frames this is because the agent can't
get a sense of motion by looking at only
one picture right nobody can get in a
sense of motion from looking at one
picture worse yet the opening I Atari
library returns a sequence of frames
where it could be a random number
between two three or four so to get a
sense of motion we have to actually
stack a set of frames and we're gonna
handle that with this function so we'll
just keep a running stack of frames the
current frame to save and the buffer
size which just tells you how many
frames to save so at the top of the
episode you're not gonna have anything
to save all right there will be no
stacked frames
so you want to initialize it so to be
the buffer size by the shape of each
individual frame next you want to
iterate over that and say each row which
corresponds to each image in your stack
gets assigned to a frame so otherwise
it's not the beginning of the episode
and you want to pop off the bottom
observation shift the set of frames down
and append the new observation to the
end so instead of one two three four
it'll be two three four and then frame
five so let's do that equals sorry zero
two buffer size minus one so this will
shift everything down
and this will upend the current frame to
the end of the stack next we have to do
a reshape and this is basically to make
everything play nicely with the neural
network all right now we're ready for
our main function let's go ahead and
save scroll down
good grief breakout b0 is the name of
the environment this is just a flag to
determine if you want to load a
checkpoint
sorry so yeah epsilon starts out at 1.0
so the agent takes purely random actions
our learning rate alpha will be
something small by zero zero zero two
five and we've reshaped our input so it
needs to be 180 instead of 210 180 by
160 by 4 because we're gonna stack four
frames the breakout library that's right
the breakout game has three actions and
a memory size of 25,000 which as I said
takes about 48 gigabytes of RAM so go
ahead and scale that based on however
much you have if you have 16 gigs go
ahead and reduce it by down to something
like 6 or 7,000 so the batch size tells
us how many batches of memories to
include for our training we use 32 if
flow checkpoint is true then we want to
load the models next thing we need is a
way of keeping track of the scores we
will need a parameter for the number of
games stick with 200 to start with a
stack size of 4 and an initial score of
0 so the memory is originally
initialized with a bunch of zeros that
is perfectly acceptable but another
option something else we can do is we
can overwrite those zeros with actual
gameplay sampled from the environment so
why don't we do that so and the actions
are just chosen randomly right it's just
to give the agent some idea of what is
going on in the environment so you want
to reset at the top of every episode
you want to pre-process that observation
you want to go ahead and stack the
frames and then play your episode so
there's a bit of a quirk here the the
agent saves its actions as zero one or
two but the actions in the environment
are actually one two and three so we
have to sample from that interval and
then add one take the action subtract
one and then save the the transition in
the memory just a bit of a kludge not a
big problem so then we want to add that
to our stack
go ahead and subtract off one from the
action and store that transition in
memory and then finally set the old
observation to be the new one let's go
ahead and use a string print statement
okay now that we've loaded up our agent
with random memories we can actually go
ahead and play the game
one thing I like to do is print out the
running average of the last ten games so
that we get an idea of if the agent is
learning over not over time or not you
do it like this and then just print that
out
and I also like to know if epsilon is
still won or if it has actually started
to decrease over time and we also want
to save the models every 10 games and if
on any other game we just want to print
out the episode number and the score so
we can actually scroll up here copy this
not done whoops there we go so instead
of a random choice it is agent thought
choose action and that takes in the
observation oh but we did forget to do
the same thing here grab those and put
them there so the top of every episode
we reset the environment pre-process the
observation and stack the frame is quite
critical so when you still have to do
the same thing with adding and
subtracting one we want to save the
transitions and the only other
difference is that we want to learn at
every step and at the end of the episode
we want to go ahead and append our score
so that way we can keep track of our
average and if you want to get fancy you
can go ahead and add in a plotting
function so that when this is done
learning you can plop learning over time
and you should see an upward slope over
time and if you want to plot the epsilon
so you should see a gradual downward
slope as well so I'm gonna leave it here
because the model is still training on
my computer it's run about 3,000
iterations 3,000 games that is and it at
best it gets two to three points per set
of five lives so it's really gonna need
a couple days of training to get up to
anything resembling competitive gameplay
but once it's done I'll upload another
video that explains how Q learning works
in depth and in detail and I'll include
the performance from this particular
model in that video so you can check it
out then feel free to run this yourself
one
I finish the model I will go ahead and
upload the train version to my github so
you are free to download it if you don't
have any hard any decent GPUs to train
this with go ahead leave a comment down
below subscribe I will see you all in
the next video
you
welcome back everybody in this series of
videos we're going to code up a deep Q
network invite aurash to play space
invaders from the Atari open a gym
library in this first video we're gonna
code the convolutional neural network
class and the second video will code up
the aging class itself and in the third
we'll get to coding the main loop and
seeing how it all performs let's get to
it
so if you're not familiar with the DBQ
Network I would advise you to check out
my earlier video bite size machine
learning what is a DBQ network is a
quick little explainer video that gives
you the gist of it within about 4 and
1/2 minutes if you already know then
great we're ready to rock and roll but
if you don't I'll give you the brief too
long didn't read so basic idea is that
we want to reduce some rather large
state space into something more
manageable so we're going to use a
convolutional neural network to reduce
the representation of our state space
into something more manageable and
that'll be fed into a fully connected
neural network to compute the Q value so
in other words the action values for any
particular given State we're gonna
leverage two different networks a
network that is going to tell us the
value of the current state as well as a
network to tell us the value of these
successor states this is going to be
used to calculate the values of the
target and which is the purely greedy
action as well as the behavioral network
which is the current predicted States
the difference between those two is used
in the loss function for our stochastic
gradient descent or root mean squared
propagator so let's go ahead an get
started we're gonna start as usual by
doing our imports and there are quite a
few in pi torch great library one thing
I really like about it is that it's
highly expressive you don't have a whole
lot of boilerplate code as you do in
something like tensorflow tens flows
enormous lis powerful and if you want to
do cross app type of software then
that's going to be really your only
choice
for our purposes this is going to be
precise we want to use and of course
numpy so we're going to define a class
for our deep Q Network and that will
derive from an end module this is kind
of how my torch handles everything you
want to derive your class from the
module the base module so that way you
get access to all of the goodies
and we'll pass in our learning rate
alpha for our stochastic gradient
descent algorithm all right so the
network is comprised of three
convolutional layers and two fully
connected layers so the first one is
just going to be a two-dimensional
convolution that's going to take one
input channel the reason is that the
agent doesn't really care about color so
we're going to go ahead and make things
easier to reduce our computational
requirements by going to a grayscale
representation
we'll take 32 filters with an 8x8 kernel
a stride of four and a padding of one
second layer is going to be pretty
similar this one of course will take 32
channels in give 64 channels out and do
a four by four kernel with a stride of
two and our third convolutional layer is
going to be of course two-dimensional as
well
it takes in 64 outputs 128 with a three
by three kernel that's it for the
convolutions a if you don't know how
accomplished a neural network works I'm
gonna go ahead and link a video here
that will give you the the the basic
idea of how those work and if you would
rather see how how this stuff works in
text form I don't know if I mentioned
this earlier but there is an Associated
blog article my website neural net
thought a I yeah I bought that domain
I'll link it in the description go ahead
and check it out please so our fully
connected layer is the following and
we're gonna have to do a little bit of
magic here so after running this stuff a
bunch of times I know the dimensionality
of the images we're gonna of the
convolutions we're going to get out and
what we want to know is we're going to
be taking a set of filters
you know convolved images that have had
filters applied to them 128 to be exact
and we want to unroll them into a single
and image right to feed into our neural
network so that's gonna be a hundred
twenty-eight channels that are nineteen
by eight in size and that's a magic
number I got from just by running the
code and trial and error and then our
output layer is going to take in those
512 units and output 6y6 that's because
we have a total of six actions in the
game of space invaders you have a total
of six actions which are the subset of
the full twenty available in the atari
library basically the agent can do
nothing it can move left it can move
right it can shoot while standing still
and it can move left and right and shoot
when we get to the main video go ahead
and show all those actions we also need
an optimizer equals opt-in Armus prop
and we want to tell it to take the
parameters of our object for the weights
and our learning rate is going to be
alpha that we've passed in our loss
function is going to be a mean square
error loss and the components of that
will be the target and the current
predicted q functions and of course the
target is just the agree D value right
because Q learning is an off policy
method that uses a epsilon greedy
behavior policy to update the purely
greedy target policy another thing we
have to do in pi torch is tell it which
device we're using so t dot device and
that'll be cuda 0 if T cuda is available
else cpu and what this is telling it is
that if the GPUs available go ahead and
use it which is of course always
preferable otherwise just use the CPU
and we also have to tell it to actually
send the network to the device maybe an
amusing 0.4 I don't know if n 1.0 that's
actually required but as of the time I'm
coding this up it's required so
something we had to live with okay so
this is the sum and the whole of our
network
only thing or that remains to do is to
feed forward our observation and that
will take the ops
no.not observation observation not only
can I not type I cannot speak as well
I suck at life I don't know why you guys
listen to me so what we want to do is
the observation vector is the we're
going to use a sequence of frames and
those frames are the reduced images from
the screen so when we get to the third
video on on actually playing the game
you'll see that you don't need the full
frame to actually figure out what's
going on you can actually truncate it to
get a really good idea in particular the
agent can only move left and right a
certain amount so we go ahead and
truncate the sides you don't need the
score at the top because we're keeping
track of the score so you don't need to
some of the bottom so you can actually
truncate the image a little bit to
reduce your memory requirements and
we're going to convert it into a
grayscale so we get rid of to it we're
just going to average the three channels
to make them into one and we also have
to pass in a sequence of frames right
because if I only show you one frame of
the video game you can't tell what's
going on you don't get a sense of motion
from a single frame right you need at
least two to get a sense of motion we'll
be using three I believe in the original
implementation of this algorithm for for
deep mind they used to form we're gonna
go ahead and use three just to be
different I haven't I suspect that's a
hyper parameter it's not something I
played with I encourage you to do that
Oh another thing is that we must train
this on a GPU if you try to do it on a
GPU it's gonna take 7,000 years so if
you do not have access to a GPU go ahead
and leave a comment below and I will
find a way to get my pre trained model
to you so you can go ahead and play
around with this I have a 1080 Ti not
not top of line anymore but it's still
quite good for this particular apps
application so back to the topic we have
to convert our sequence of frames or
observation to a tensor and we have also
want to send that to the device this is
a big heal the era T of Pi torch as far
I'm aware I'm not the world's leading
expert but as far as I understand it you
got to tell it to send the network as
well as the variables to the device as
well not a big deal just something to be
aware of next thing we have to do is
resize it so when you are given a
sequence of frames in the opening ahjuma
and really any other format of image is
going to be height and width by channels
whereas if you look up here this
actually expects the channels to come
first and so we have to reshape the
array to accommodate that so PI torch is
built in phone you for that is view you
want a minus 1 to handle any number of
stacked frames one channel in the
beginning and we're gonna pass in 185 by
195 image that doesn't seem right
actually sorry it's not 195 I'm like the
original image is 210 by 160 it can't be
hundred eighty-five hundred ninety-five
total brain fart there it's 100 85 by 95
okay so we have taken in our sequence of
frames we've converted it into a tensor
and flat and converted it into the
proper proper shape for our network the
next thing we want to do is activate it
and feed it forward so we call the first
convolutional layer on our observation
and we use the r lu function to activate
it and we store that in the new variable
observation and then we learn how to
type and then we do the same thing with
that output pass it through the second
convolutional layer and then we do the
same thing again we pass through the
third convolutional layer and we're
almost home free so the next thing we
have to do is we are outputting a 128 by
19 by 8 ooh
said of arrays
next thing we have to do is oh by the
way that noise was my Pomodoro timer if
you're not using the Pomodoro Technique
I highly recommend it
it's an enormous productivity hack but
anyway next thing we have to do is take
our sequence of convolved images and
flatten them to feed into our fully
connected neural network so begin use
the View function to do that not -1 for
whatever number of frames we pass in 19
by 8 is what we get out and I found that
out through experimentation and we know
that's 128 channels because we dictate
that here right here 128 output channels
so boom we've flattened it and the only
thing that remains is to feed it forward
and we use a value activation function
there FC 1 fully connected layer 1 and
then it's not observation but its
actions self dot FC two observations so
we'll feed it through the final fully
convolve layer and store that as a
variable called actions and go ahead can
return it and the reason we're doing
that is because what we're getting out
is aq value for each of our actions and
we want to pass that back now keep in
mind that we're passing in a sequence of
frames and so we're gonna get back is a
matrix it's not going to be a single
array of six values it's gonna be six
values times whatever number of rows of
images you pass in so if we pass in
three images it's gonna have three rows
and six columns and that'll be important
later when we actually get to choosing
the actions speaking of which I'm going
to cut it short here we've already I've
already rambled for about 12 13 minutes
in part two we're going to take a look
at coding of the aging class I have
structured it this way because the agent
actually has to network so it made sense
to kind of stick the network in its own
class we'll get to coding up the agents
init function how to handle its memory
how to store transitions how to choose
actions and how to actually implement
the learning
that's a much longer project so we'll
stick that in its own video and then in
part three we're gonna get to actually
coding of the main loop and seeing how
it performs hey if you liked the video
make sure to like the video hey if you
don't like it go ahead the thumbs down I
don't really care let me know what you
think questions comments leave them down
below if you made it this far please
consider subscribing I look forward to
seeing all of you in the next video
welcome back everybody in the previous
video we got decoding the convolutional
neural network class for our deep Q
learning agent that's going to play
space invaders if you haven't seen that
yet go and click the link to go ahead
and watch at first otherwise you
probably won't know what's going on if
you're the kind if you're the type of
person that would prefer to have a
written set of instructions go ahead and
click the link down below I'll link to
the Associated blog article for this
particular tutorial series when we last
left off we just finished returning the
set of actions which is the set of Q
values for our sequence of frames so of
course in this video we're gonna go
ahead and get started coding up the
agent class which is where all the magic
is gonna happen oh and of course as
always I have left the code for this in
my github under the YouTube directory it
gets its own directory because there's a
few different files here I'll link that
below as well and if you aren't
following me on get up you probably
should because that's where I post all
my stuff okay next up we have the agent
classroom and this is just going to
derive from the base object class
nothing fancy here
we need a basic init function and this
is going to take gamma which is our
discount factor so the agent has a
choice of how to value future rewards in
general gets discounted by some value
because a reward now is worth more than
a reward in the future just like with us
you need epsilon for our epsilon greedy
action selection the alpha for the
learning rate the max memory size a
variable to keep track of how low we
want epsilon to go something to keep
track of how long we replace how often
we're going to replace our target
Network I'll get to that in a moment
or in a few minutes and the action space
and that's just a list of variables from
0 through 5 those correspond to all the
possible actions for our agents and you
just set these to the appropriate
variables being careful not to turn on
your caps lock key so what these all are
are just hyper parameters for our agents
we don't need to store alpha because
we're just going to pass it in to the
network and then never touch it again
storing the action space allows us to
accommodate the epsilon greedy action
selection later the men's size is used
for efficiency purposes so we're going
to keep track of state action reward
transitions you don't want to store an
infinite number of them you only want to
store a subset you don't need to store
all of them anyway there's no more
practical benefits as we're just
sampling a subset anyway so we just use
some rather large memory to keep track
of all of the state transitions that we
care about keep track of how many steps
and the learn step counter that is to
keep track of how many times the agent
has called the learn function that is
used for target network replacement if
you're not familiar with it target
network replacement is when you swap the
parameters from the evaluation network
to the target Network my experience has
been that it doesn't actually help
things so I'm not going to do it I'm
going to code it in because it's an
important part of the topic but in this
particular case I haven't found it to be
helpful but I am played with it too much
I saw that it does quite well without it
so why break it so I'm going to store
the memory as a list and the reason I'll
use a list instead of a numpy array is
because the associated cost of stacking
numpy rays is really really high so it's
much much faster to store a list of
Lists and then convert to a numpy array
when you learn
and that's much faster than keeping
track of a set of an umpire arrays and
just stacking them the stack operation
is incredibly computationally
prohibitive so for something like this
that's already computationally expensive
doesn't make any sense
[Music]
and keep track of the total number of
memories stored so that way you don't
overwrite the array we want to keep
track of how often we want to replace
the target Network and then we need our
two networks cue eval and that is just
pass in the Alpha that is just the
agents estimate of the current set of
states and cue next is the agents
estimates of the successor set of states
so recall in deep Q learning we
calculate the value the max value of the
successor state as our greedy action
that's our our actual target policy and
our behavior policy that we use to
generate data is epsilon greedy that's
it for our constructor the next thing we
have to worry about is storing memory
transitions so transmission so we are
interested in the current state the
action taken the reward received and the
resulting state because those are the
things that that allow the agent to
learn so we have to make sure that we
aren't over our memory so if the mem
counter is less than self dot mem size
then just go ahead and append that as a
list and again we're doing this because
it is much cheaper computationally to
append alistun it is to actually stack a
numpy array if we have filled up our
memory then we want to overwrite the
position and memory that is determined
by the modulus
but men's size so this will guarantee we
are bounded by his zero all the way up
to our menses and of course this is a
list of lists
it's just state action or award state
underscore and we want to increment the
memory counter pretty simple huh
pretty straightforward next up we have
the function to choose an action and
this will take the observation and again
just to remind you as we discussed in
the first video we were passing in a
sequence of observations because we want
to capture some information about the
temporal dependence of what's going on
again with one frame you can't tell if
the aliens are moving left or right and
so you don't know if you should move
left or right of course you know which
way your Bo let's go you know which way
there is go but as far as movements
concerned you need at least one frame so
as always we're going to be using numpy
to calculate a random number for us to
our epsilon greedy action selection and
you want to get the value of all of the
actions for the current set of states
self cute eval dot forward so what we're
doing now is for propagating that stack
of frames through the neural network the
convolutional neural network and the
fully connected layer to get the value
of each of each of the actions given the
you're in some set of states denoted by
the observation so if rain is less than
1 minus epsilon then you want to take
the Arg max write the maximum action and
recall that we have stored the actions
as a matrix the return is a matrix
because you have the number of rows that
correspond to the number of frames you
pass in and each of the columns
correspond to each of the six actions
so you want to take the first first axis
and if you're taking a random action
then you just choose something at random
from the action space list and go ahead
and increment your steps and return the
action that you've chosen the way I the
reason I use one minus Epsilon is you
can use the probability epsilon we can
use the probability 1 minus Epsilon this
is really a more of an soft soft Epsilon
kind of strategy rather than purely
greedy but it doesn't really matter this
is going to give you the probability of
choosing the maximum action of epsilon
plus epsilon over 6 because there of
course the greedy action is the subset
of all actions so there's a 1 over 6
probability that when you take the
quote-unquote non greedy action you'll
actually end up getting the greedy
action right next thing we have to worry
about is how the agent is going to learn
and this is really the meat of
everything so we are doing batch
learning so you want to pass in a batch
size and the reason we're doing batch
learning is a number of different
reasons so you want to break
correlations between state transitions
you it's even ok if the the batch
overlaps different episodes but you want
to get is a good subsampling of the
overall parameter space so that way you
don't get trapped in the local minima so
you randomly sample these state
transitions through your memory
otherwise you could end up if you were
play the whole memory you could end up
getting trapped in some local minimum
it's a way to improve the efficiency of
the algorithm to converge to a purely
optimal strategy excuse me
Thursday all right first thing we have
to do since we're using batch learning
is we have to zero out our gradients and
what this means is that the grades can
accumulate from step to step the network
the PI torch library can keep track of
it we don't want that if you do that if
you don't do the zero grad then you'll
end up with basically accumulating for
every single batch and that's really
full learning rather than batch learning
next thing we have to check for is if
we're going to replace a target Network
so if it's not none and if it's time to
do it release now replace target count
equals zero then we want to actually
replace our target Network what we do
there is we take advantage of the PI
torts representation of our network in
that case it's just we can convert our
entire network into a dictionary which
is really cool so it's self queue next
load States dipped so it's going to load
a state to the network from a dictionary
which network the evaluation network
which we're going to convert to a state
dictionary we're not actually going to
use this in our employment ation but I
included here for completeness next up
we want to know we want to select a
random sub sample of the memory so want
to make sure we don't go all the way
past the end of our array so if our
current memory counter plus batch size
is less than our total memory then we're
free to go ahead and select any point of
our memory because we know we're not
going to go beyond it
range otherwise if there is an overlap
then we want to mem start to just be an
int in the range good grief I hate that
minus one just to be safe okay so that
is how we choose where to start just
andum number somewhere between zero and
the max memory if we have enough left
over in the memory for the bat to
accommodate the batch otherwise subtract
that off and select something from that
subset then we're gonna go ahead and get
that mini batch and convert that to a
number right so I suspect this is not
the most efficient way of doing this and
the reason is that you run into some
difficulties in the way in which you
pass things into the torch library and
as a certain set of expectations that
are kind of finicky not to say it's bad
it's just something that I wasn't
expecting but it works nonetheless so
what we want to do next is feed-forward
both of our networks we want to know
what is the value of our current state
and what is the value of the successor
state after we take the action whatever
action we're looking at in our batch so
that's just QE Val forward what are we
feeding forward here's where we got some
happiness we've got to convert it into a
list and the reason is that our memory
is a numpy array of numpy objects
because the observation vectors are
numpy objects so if you don't convert it
into a list then you have a numpy array
of nd array on Dex and tensor PI torts
will complain
we don't want tensor you don't want pi
torch to complain so we want to access
all all rows right our entire batch and
the state is just the zeroth element and
you want all of the variable you want
all of the pixels so you need the second
set of : there and we want to send this
to the device so if that Q eval dot
device and this ensures that the this
network this set of variables gets sent
to our GPU as well and the next thing we
need is the value of the successor
States and that is just all the rows
third column and all of the all of the
members of that array and here I've just
no I got us quit using the visual studio
code this is annoying but scroll up here
so all I have done here is I'm putting
it on cue eval dot device because the
device for both the evaluation and the
next network are the same so I only one
GPU by two GPUs then this would matter
it doesn't matter so you just call it
that next thing we want to know is what
is the max action for our current for
our next state right because the update
rule actually calculates takes into
account the purely greedy action for the
successor state maybe I can find an
image of what I'll flash it here on the
screen to make life easy but next thing
we have to know is the max action and we
use the Arg max function for that and
remember we want to take the first
dimension because we're the actions
queue next to predicted and queue next
are actually our actions that's what we
get from the feed forward and that is
batch size times number of actions and
we want the number of actions so that's
first dimension
and I am a little bit in awe retentive
here by sending you to the device just
to make sure nothing gets off the device
because this stuff slows to a crawl if
you run out of the CPU we need to get
our rewards and that is obtained from
our memory all the rows and the second
element 20 parentheses and one thing we
want is our loss function to be zero for
every action except for that max action
so we have Q target equal Q predicted
but we want Q target for all of our
entire match but the max action to be
rewards plus self dot gamma times the
actual value of that action so T dot max
just gives you the value of the maximum
element and Arg max gives you the index
and you want to find the maximum action
the value of it so those are our target
and predicted values that's what we used
to update our loss function the next
thing we have to handle is the epsilon
decrement so we want the agent to
gradually converge on a purely a greedy
strategy for its behavior policy and the
way you do that is by gradually
decreasing epsilon over time I don't
like to let it simply go to start
decreasing right away so I have some set
number of steps I let it run first and I
use a linear decrease over time you can
use exponential quadratic you can use
what a reform you want it's not to my
knowledge it's not super critical but I
could be completely wrong this seems to
work as we'll see in the third video
so if we don't have enough left then
just set it to epsilon end scroll up
here and we're almost done so we have
everything we need we have everything we
need to compute our loss which is this Q
target and Q predicted those are the
values of Q predicted is the value of
the current set of states and Q target
is related to Q next right
it's the Q target is the max action for
the next successor State and so we're
almost there so the loss is just the
mean squared error loss if you recall
from the first video where we define the
loss function and as is the torch style
you have to send it to the device and
then we want to back propagate with lost
backward and we just want to step
perform one iteration and go ahead and
increment our learn step counter and
that's basically it so there was a lot
of code there let's go back and take a
look really quick so first thing you
want to do is 0 your gradients so that
way we're doing actual batch
optimization instead of full
optimization then we want to check to
see if we're gonna if it's if we are
going to replace the target networking
if it is time and if it is load the
state dictionary from the Q eval on to
the Q next network
next up calculate the start of the bet
of the memory subsampling I'm making
sure to get some subset of the array go
ahead and sample that batch of memory
and converted to an umpire array Oh
Pomodoro timer so if you guys aren't
using the Pomodoro method to work I
highly recommend it go look that up if
you don't know what it is but anyway
convert that to an umpire array and then
go ahead and feed forward the the
current state and the successor state
you
using the memory subsample making sure
it is sent to your device
next thing we have to know is the
maximum action for the successor state
and calculate the rewards that the agent
was given set the cue target to cue
predicted because we want a loss for
every state except them the loss for
every action except the max action to be
zero and then update the value of Q
target for the max action to be equal to
rewards plus gamma times the actual
value of that max action next up make
sure that you're using some way of
decrementing epsilon over time so it
should it converges to some small value
that makes the agent settle on an mostly
greedy strategy in this clay in this
case I'm using 5% of the time for a
random action finally go ahead and
calculate the loss function back
propagated step your optimizer and
increment your step counter and that is
all she wrote for the learn function and
the aging class slightly more code than
in the network class but still fairly we
have a type of they're still fairly
straightforward I hope this has been
informative and in part three we're
gonna go ahead and code of the main loop
and see how all this performs I look
forward to seeing you in the next video
any comments questions suggestions go
ahead and leave them below if you made
it this far please consider subscribing
I look forward to seeing you all in the
next video and welcome back every to
part three of coding a deep Q learning
agent in the open AI gym atari library
and parts 1 & 2 we took a look at the
deep neural network class as well as the
agent class for our agent and in part
three we're going to finally put it all
together into the main loop to play the
game and see how our agent does let's
get started
you
so we begin as usual with our typical
imports we're gonna need the gym of
course and we're gonna need to import
our or model class so from model on
import deep sorry deep queue model and
agents and I also have a utility
function I'm not going to go over the
code issues a trivial function to post
the to print the plot the decaying
epsilon and the running average of
previous five scores from utils import
learning and oh and by the way so if you
haven't seen parts one and two go ahead
check those out and if you want the code
for this please check out my github if
you would like to see a blog article
that details all this in text if you
missed something on the speech then go
ahead and click the link down below so
it's giving me some issue oh it's not
deep Q model this is the the downside of
talking and typing at the same time I'm
not that talented so we want to go ahead
and make our environment and the space
invaders V 0 another thing to know is
that there are implementations of the
environment where instead of being
passed back an image of the screen
you're passed back like a ram image
something like that never use it sounds
kind of interesting it may be something
for you to check out and leave a comment
down below if you've played with having
experience with it or if you think it
sounds cool so we want to make our agent
and I'm gonna call it brain big brain
pinky in the brain baby gamma 0.95 and
epsilon of 1.0 and I'm using epsilon at
one point zero because it starts out
taking purely random actions and
converges on a mostly greedy strategy
learning rate of 0.03 max memory size
5,000 transitions and we're not going to
do any replacement so you may have
noticed when we were building our agent
that the memory was instantiated as an
empty list if you're going to use an
umpire race one thing you would do is
just create an array of zeros and the
shape of you know your images as well as
the total number of memories I'm gonna
do something slightly different so one
way to help agents learn is to actually
have them watch videos of humans playing
and in fact the deep mind team taught
alpha alpha zero go to play by showing
abort configurations and saying which
which player one
so you it's perfectly legitimate to
leverage the experience of humans I'm
not gonna play the game for the agent
but what I'm gonna do is allow the agent
to play the game at totally random it's
just gonna play a set number of games to
fill up its memory using totally random
actions so it's a bit of a hack but I
kind of I don't know to me it seems
legitimate but some people may frown
upon it I don't really care it's how I
chose to solve the problem and it seems
to work fairly well so brain dam Emma
sighs we have to reset your environment
reset you're done flag and play an
episode so here i'ma let you know the
action so zero is no action one is fire
two is move right threes move left four
is move right fire five is move left
fire so that's zero through five total
of six actions choose one at random in V
that action space sample if you want to
verify that these do that go ahead and
code up a simple loop you know while
loop while not done take action zero and
render it and see what it does so next
you want to go ahead and take that
action
and the other thing I do is the and I'm
on the fence about doing this I haven't
tested it but in my experience with
other environments in more basic
algorithms that my experience is that it
makes sense to penalize the agent for
losing so you don't want the agent will
naturally try to maximize its score but
you want it to know that losing is
really bad so if you're done and the and
this may be something I change on the
github so if you go to the github and
see this isn't there it means that I
tested it and decided it was stupid
but as of right now I think it's okay
I'm always open to change my mind though
so I want to let it know that losing
really really sucks and I want to store
that transition and here's a bit of a
magical part so as I said in the in the
first video in the convolutional neural
network we want to reshape it down from
three channels into one because the the
agent doesn't really care about color it
only cares about is an enemy there or
not right and I think of the information
from black and white so I'm gonna take
the mean over the three channels to get
down to a single Channel and I'm also
going to go ahead and truncate it and
the reason is that there isn't a whole
lot of information around the borders of
the screen that the agent needs so we
can get away with reducing our memory
requirements without losing anything
meaningful and I'm going to go ahead and
flash in some images here of what that
looks like but what I do is take the ops
observation vector and I'm gonna take 15
to 230 to 125 and the mean is performed
over access to and we also want to store
our action and reward you guys can't see
that there so we store the action and
reward as well as
let's go ahead and copy this we also
want to copy we also want to store the
successor state oh good grief
life is so hard there we go
and that's observation underscore which
is which is the successor state and then
set your observation to observation
underscore and then when you're done
just let yourself know okay okay and we
are almost there so next thing you want
to do is keep track of the score so you
don't know how well the agent is doing
I had this variable Epsilon history Oh
keep track of the history of epsilon
says the decreases over time because we
want to know the relationship between
the score and the epsilon and we'll run
it for 50 games and we'll take a batch
size of 32 memories the batch size is an
important hyper parameter but what you
find is that using a larger batch size
may get you a little bit better
performance it slows down training
tremendously so on my system within I
seven so we need 20 X 32 gigs of ram 10
atti
batch size of 32 means that 50 games is
gonna run in about a half an hour and it
takes quite a bit of time using a larger
batch size doesn't seem to produce a
whole lot better performance but it
certainly slows it down by more than a
factor of two so then there's nonlinear
scaling there and we want to know that
we're starting game I plus 1 with an
epsilon of something dot say four
significant figures
right now it Upsilon and we want to go
ahead and append the agents epsilon at
the beginning of the episode reset our
done flag and reset our environment and
okay so the next thing we want to do is
as I said why is this unhappy invalid
syntax oh now I've offended it what have
I done
Oh forgot a comma there we go so next
thing we want to do is construct our
sequence of frames as I said we're going
to pass in some sequence of frames to
allow it to get some conception of
movements in the system so I have a
rather ugly way of doing this as usual
but the first thing I want to pass into
it is the first the first observation
vector from the beginning of the game
and I have broken something again
what have I broken frames none by some
oh of course of course
okay so the score for this episode is 0
I want to keep track of the last action
so this is something I'm not sure about
I must confess to you guys the
documentation on the open a IgM is
rather lackluster what it says is that
each action will be repeated for K
frames where K's the set two three or
four so I guess it gets repeated some
random number times so since I don't
know how many times and I want to keep
passing in a consistent set of
observation vectors of frames I will do
something hacky so I'll keep track of
the last action and I will only update
my action every third action so I want
as pass in to see
two three frames and repeat the action
three times I'm kind of forcing the
issue again it seems to work I don't
think it's the best implementation but
this is you know just my quick and dirty
implementation so if we have three
frames go ahead and choose an action
based on those and reset your frame
variable to an empty list otherwise go
ahead and do what you just did
scroll down so then we want to go ahead
and take that action keep track of our
score and append our new observation I'm
just gonna copy that
yep copy that
and then I am going to go ahead and tell
it that losing is very bad we don't like
losers and this l dot lives thing is the
number of lives the agent has kale is
just the emulator in which the opening
at our opening items Atari libraries
built and next we have to store a
transition I'm going to copy that code
precisely because I have fat fingers and
apparently screw things up so copy that
and then underscore brain learn batch
size keep track of our action and here
you can put in a render if you want to
see what it's doing if not then at the
end of the episode end of the episode
you know to append a score which we're
going to plot later
and I like to print the score so that I
can kind of get an idea of how the agent
is doing and we need to make a list of
the X variable for plotting function
again for the plotting function just go
ahead and check out my github for that
that's the easiest way and I'm gonna set
a file name I'm just gonna call it test
for now plus strain num game something
like that plus dot PNG so we have a file
name and then we're gonna plot that we
want to plot the score is the epsilon
history and the file and pass in the
file name so that it saves it and that's
all she wrote for the for the main loop
I've gone ahead and run that so I'm
gonna go ahead and flash in the results
here so as you can see the epsilon
decreases somewhat linearly over time
not somewhat completely linearly and as
it does so the agents performance
gradually increases over time and keep
in mind here I am plotting the previous
the average of the previous five games
the reason I do that is to account for
significant variations in game to game
play right so the agent is always gonna
choose some proportion of random actions
and that means it can randomly choose to
move left or right into the enemy's
bullets so there's always some games
that it's gonna get cut short so the
general trend in the performance is up
up until the very end when it actually
takes a bit of a dive and I've seen this
over many many different iterations I
suspect this has to do with the way that
it is navigating through parameter space
so to find pretty good pockets and then
kind of shift into a related other local
minima what isn't quite as good
if you let it run long enough this will
eventually go back up but it does have
some a Silla Tory behavior to it but you
can see that it increases its score
quite dramatically and in this
particular set of runs I saw scores in
excess of 700 points which is actually
pretty good for an agent so let's go
ahead and take a look at what it looks
like with the target network replacement
so here you can see a dramatically
different behavior so in this case
epsilon decreases and the score actually
decreases over time and you know
actually I don't quite know why it does
this so the the oscillations down there
are almost certainly from the target
Network replacements it could be a fluke
but I have run this several times where
I see this type of behavior where with
the target never replacement it totally
takes a nosedive I don't think I screwed
up my implementation please leave a
comment below if he saw something it
looks off but as far as I can tell it
looks it's implemented correctly just
copy one state dick to another nor a big
mystery there but that's why I choose to
leave it off you get a significant
variation and performance more of the
stories to go ahead and leave the target
network replacement off and that's it
for this series so we have made an agent
to play the Atari Atari game of space
invaders by gradually decreasing epsilon
over time we get really good performance
several hundred points in fact actually
learns how to play the game quite well
probably going to go ahead and spin in a
video of it playing here so you can see
how it looks
if this has been helpful to you please
consider subscribing go ahead and leave
a comment below if you have one a
question suggestion anything go ahead
and I answer and read all my comments
and go ahead and smash that like button
guys so I hope to see you all in the
next video and take care in this video
I'm going to tell you everything you
need to know to start solving
reinforcement learning problems with
policy gradient methods I'm gonna give
you the algorithm and the limitation
details upfront and then we'll go into
how it all works and why you would want
to do it let's get to it
so here's a basic idea behind policy
gradient methods a policy is just a
probability distribution the agent uses
to pick actions so we use a deep neural
network to approximate the agents policy
the network takes observations of the
environment as input and outputs actions
selected according to a softmax
activation function next generate an
episode and keep track of the state's
actions and rewards in the agent's
memory at the end of each episode go
back through these States actions and
rewards and compete and compute the
discounted future returns at each time
step use those returns as weights and
the actions the agent took as labels to
perform back propagation and update the
weights of your deep neural network and
just repeat until you have a kick-ass
agent simple yeah so now we know the
what let's unpack how all this works and
why it's something worth doing remember
with the reinforcement learning we're
trying to maximize the ages performance
over time let's say the agents
performance is characterized by some
function J and it's a function of the
weights theta of the deep neural network
so our update rule for theta is that the
new theta equals the old theta plus some
learning rate times the gradient of that
performance metric note that we want to
increase performance over time so this
is technically gradient ascent instead
of gradient descent
the gradient of this performance metric
is going to be proportional to some
overstates for the amount of time we
spend in any given state and a sum over
actions for the value of the state
action pairs and the gradient of the
policy where of course the policy is
just the probability of taking each
action given we're in some state this is
really an expectation value and after a
little manipulation we arrive at the
following expression when you plug that
into the update rule for theta you get
this other expression there are two
important features here this G sub T
term is the discounted feature returns
we referenced in the opening and this
grading of the policy divided by the
policy is a vector that tells us the
direction in policy space that maximize
the chance that we repeat the action a
sub T when you multiply the two you get
a vector that increases the probability
of taking actions with high expected
future returns this is precisely how the
agent learns over time and what makes
policy gradient methods so powerful this
is called the reinforce however by the
way if we think about this long enough
some problems start to appear for one it
doesn't seem very sample efficient at
the top of each episode we reset the
aeneas memory so it effectively discards
all its previous experience aside from
the new weights that parameterize its
policy it's kind of starting to a
scratch after every time it learns worse
yet if the agent has some big
probability of selecting any action in
any given State how can we control the
variation between the episodes for our
state spaces lots are way too many
combinations to consider well that's
actually a non-trivial problem of policy
gradient methods then part of the reason
our agent wasn't so great at Space
Invaders obviously no reinforcement
learning method is going to be perfect
and we'll get to the solution to both of
these problems here in a minute but
first let's talk about why we would want
to use policy grades at all given these
shortcomings the policy gradient method
is a pretty different approach to
reinforcement learning many
reinforcement learning algorithms like
deep
q-learning for instance when I am
estimating the value of a state or state
action pair in other words the agent
wants to know how valuable each state is
so that it's Epsilon greedy policy can
let it select the action that leads to
the most valuable states DG repeats this
process over and over
occasionally choosing random actions to
see if it's missing something the
intuition behind Epsilon greedy action
selection is really straightforward
figure out what the best action is and
take it sometimes do other stuff to make
sure you're not entirely wrong okay that
makes sense but this assumes that you
can accurately learn the action value
function to begin with in many cases the
value or action value function is
incredibly complex and really difficult
to learn on realistic time scales in
some cases the optimal policy itself may
be much simpler and therefore easier to
approximate this means the policy
grading agent can learn to beat certain
environments much more quickly than if
it relied on an algorithm like deep Q
learning another thing that makes policy
gradient methods attractive is what if
the optimal policy is actually
deterministic and really simple
environments with an obvious
deterministic policy like our grid world
example keeping a finite epsilon means
that you keep on exploring even after
you found the best possible solution
obviously this is optimal for more
complex environments the optimal policy
may very well be deterministic but
perhaps it's not so obvious and you
can't guess at it beforehand in that
case one could argue that deep Q
learning would be great because you can
always decrease the exploration factor
epsilon over time
and while the agent to settle on a
purely greedy strategy this is certainly
true but how can we know how quickly to
decrease Epsilon the beauty of policy
gradients is that even though they are
stochastic they can approach a
deterministic policy over time actions
that are optimal will be selected more
frequently and this will create a sort
of momentum that drives the agent
towards that optimal deterministic
policy this really isn't feasible in
action value algorithms that rely on
Epsilon greedy
it's variations so what about it
shortcomings as we said earlier there
are really big variations between
episodes since each time the agent
visits the state it can choose a
different action which leads to
radically different future returns the
agent also doesn't make very good use of
its prior experience since it discards
them after each time it learns while
this seem like showstoppers they have
some pretty straightforward solutions to
deal with the variance between episodes
we want to scale our rewards by some
baseline the simplest baseline to use is
the average reward from the episode and
we can further normalize the g-factor by
dividing by the standard deviation of
those rewards this helps control the
variance in their returns so that we
don't end up with wildly different step
sizes only when we perform our update to
the weights of the deep neural network
dealing with the sample and efficiency
is even easier while it's possible to
update the weights of the neural net
after each episode
nothing says this has to be the case we
can let the agent play a batch of games
so that it has a chance to visit a state
more than once before we update the
weights for our network this introduces
an additional hyper parameter which is
the batch size for our updates but the
trade-off is that we end up with a much
faster convergence to a good policy now
it may seem obvious but increasing the
batch size is what allowed me to go from
no learning at all in Space Invaders
with policy gradients to something that
actually learns how to improve its
gameplay
so that's policy gradient learning in a
nutshell we're using a deep neural
network to approximate the ages policy
and then using gradient ascent to choose
actions and results in larger returns it
may be sample inefficient and have
issues with scaling the returns but we
can deal with these problems to make
policy gradings competitive with other
reinforcement learning algorithms like
deep view learning if you've made it
this far
check out the video where I implement
policy grades in tensorflow
if you liked the video make sure to like
the video subscribe comment down below
and I'll see you in the next video
what's up everybody in this tutorial
you're gonna learn how to land a
spaceship on the moon using
policy gradient methods you don't need
to know anything about reinforcement
learning you don't need to know anything
about policy gradient methods you just
have to follow along let's get started
so before we begin let's take a look at
the basic idea of what we want to
accomplish policy gradient methods work
by approximating the policy of the agent
the policy is just the probability
distribution that the agent uses to
select actions so we're going to use a
deep neural network to approximate that
probability distribution and we're going
to be feeding in the input observations
from the environment and getting out a
probability distribution as an output
the agent learns by replaying its memory
of the rewards it received during the
episode and calculating the discounted
future rewards that followed each
particular time step those discounted
feature rewards act as weights in the
update of our deep neural network so
that the agent assigns a higher
probability to actions whose feature
rewards are higher so we'll start with
our imports and we're gonna want oh s to
handle file operations numpy to handle
numpy type our operations I mean of
course tensorflow to develop our agent
we're gonna stick everything in one
class
whose initialize function takes the
learning rate the discount factor gamma
the number of actions for the Lunar
Lander environment that's just for the
size of the first hidden layer of the
neural network will default that to 64
the size of the second hidden layer of
the deep neural network will also
default that to 64 we also need the
input dims and in this case that is 8 so
the observation isn't a pixel image it
is just a vector that represents the
state of the environment we also want a
checkpoint directory and this will be
useful for saving our model later
so this action space will be what we use
to select actions later on and we're
gonna need a number of other
administrative type stuff so for
instance the state memory is just what
the agent will use to keep track of the
states it visited likewise for the
action memory we want to keep track of
the actions the agent took and the
rewards it received along the way we
also need the layer one size and the
layer 2 size what else we okay so now we
can move on to the administrative stuff
with tensor flow so tensor flow handles
everything in what are called sessions
so we have to define one of those we're
gonna need a function to build the
network and when we return from the
network we're gonna want to initialize
all of the variables so this build
Network function is only called once it
will load up all of the variables and
operations under the tensor flow graph
and then we have to initialize those
variables with some initial values which
will be done at random
we also need a way of saving the model
because your PC may not be fast enough
to run this in a you know short amount
of time so you can do this in chunks by
saving it and then reloading it as you
have time we also need a file to save
the check points in so all right next
order of business is to actually
construct this network so we don't need
any inputs for that but we do need a set
of placeholders and the placeholders
serve as placeholders for our inputs it
just tells the tensorflow graph that hey
we're gonna be passing in some variables
we don't know what they are yet we may
not necessarily even know their shape or
size but we know what type they are and
we want to give them names so if
something goes wrong we can debug later
so this input will just be the 8 element
vector that represents the agents
observation of the environment and if
you're not really familiar with
tensorflow this idiom of saying shape
equals a list whose first element is
none tells tensorflow that we do not
know the batch size of the data we're
going to be loading so the inputs could
be 10 states it could be a hundred it
could be a thousand it could be any
number of states and so that none just
tells tensorflow hey we don't know what
shape it's gonna be so you know just
take whatever and this label is going to
be the actions the agent took during the
course of the episode this will be used
in calculating our loss function
similarly we have something called G and
G is just the generic name for the
agents discounted future rewards
following each time step this is what we
will use to bias the agents loss
function towards increasing the
probability of actions who generate the
most returns over time
so now we're going to construct our
network so the first layer will just be
the input and the number of it'll take a
course number of input and input dims on
input and then output the layer one size
and the activation is just going to be a
row u function and then we have to worry
about initializing this so when we call
the TF global variables initializer it's
going to initialize all of the layers
and variables with some values we can
dictate how it does that and we can
think very carefully about it so if
you've dealt with deep neural networks
in some cases you can get vanishing or
exploding gradients that cause the
values of the network predicts to you
know go to you know either really large
or really small values it produces junk
essentially there is a function that
will initialize the values of all the
layers such that they are relatively
comparable and we have a minimal risk of
that happening and that's called the
Xavier initializer
and I'm gonna want to copy that because
we're going to use that more than once
so of course the second layer just takes
the first layers input as l2 size as the
number of units with a value activation
and of course the same initializer and
l3 will be the output of our network
however we don't want to activate it
just yet so this quantity is related to
the probability sorry the policy of the
agent but the policy must have the
property that the sum of the
probabilities of taking an action you
know the sum of the probabilities for
all of the actions must equal 1 and it's
the softmax function that has that
property and we're going to separate it
out so that we can just so that it is a
little bit more clean in terms of the
the code a little bit more readable for
us but the self dot actions variable is
what will actually calculate the
probabilities of selecting some action
and that is just the softmax of the l3
and the name of that is probabilities
finally we need to well not finally but
next we need to calculate the loss
function so you'll stick that in a
separate scope and what we need is the
negative log probability so excuse me
the calculation involves the natural log
of the policy and you want to take the
gradient of the natural log of something
so we need a function that matches that
property so call it neg log probability
and that's the sparse softmax
cross-entropy
with log it's try saying that five times
fast so log that's is just l3 and this
is important because this is part of the
reason we separated out l3 inactions
because when you're passing in the log
gets you don't want it to already be
activated because the negative the spar
softmax cross-entropy will handle the
softmax activation function and the
labels will just be the label that we
pass in from the placeholder and then of
course be the actions the agent took and
so the loss is then that quantity
negligibly multiplied by the returns
gene next we need the training operation
and that of course is just our a great
descent type algorithm in this case
we'll use the atom optimizer the
learning rate of whatever we dictate in
the constructor and we want to minimize
that loss so that is the sum and whole
of the deep neural network where we need
to we need to code the next question we
have is how can we select actions for
the agent so the agent is attempting to
model its own probability distribution
for selecting actions so that means what
we want to do is take a state as input
pass it through the network and get out
that probability distribution at the end
given by the variable self dot actions
and then we can use numpy to select a
random action according to that
probability distribution and we're just
going to go ahead and reshape this bill
at ease
so when you run an operation through the
tensorflow graph you need to specify a
feed dictionary which gives the graph
all of the input placeholder variables
it's expecting so in this case it wants
self dot input and that takes state as
input and it's going to return a tuple
so we're going to take the zeroth
element as so we can get the correct
value that we want and then we can
select an action according to an umpire
random choice from the action space
using the probabilities as our
distribution and we just returned that
action the next problem we have to deal
with is storing in action sorry the
transitions and of course will store the
states and action and reward and this
will be useful when we learn and since
we're using lists here we're just going
to append the elements to the end of the
list
next we come to the meet of the problem
the learning function and this doesn't
require any input so the basic idea here
is that we are going to convert these
lists into numpy array so we can more
easily manipulate them and then we're
going to iterate through the agents
memory of the rewards that received and
calculate the discounted sum of rewards
that followed each time step so we're
going to need two for loops and a
variable to keep track of the sum as
well as something to keep track of our
discounting so let's deal with the
memories first
that won't work will it there we go so
now will instantiate our G factor and
get in shape of reward memory we will
iterate over the length of that memory
which is just length of our episode and
so for each time step we want to
calculate the sum of the rewards that
follow that time step is that correct
yes next we take the sum and discount it
then of course the discount is just the
gamma to the K where K is our time step
so then of course the rewards following
the teeth the teeth tongue teeth the tea
time step is just G some so that's the
some that's the way to dis kind of
rewards the next thing we have to think
about is these rewards can vary a lot
between episodes so to promote stability
in our algorithm we want to scale these
results by some number it turns out that
a reasonable number to use is the mean
so we're gonna subtract off the mean of
the rewards the agent received during
the episode and then divided by the
standard deviation and this will give us
some nice scaled and normalized numbers
such that the algorithm doesn't produce
wonky results and since we're dividing
by the standard deviation we have to
account for the possibility that the
standard deviation could be zero hence
the conditional statement next we have
to run our training operation so the
underscore tells us we don't really care
about what it returns well we have to
run the training operation with the feed
dictionary that'll take an input which
is just our state memory it will take
the labels and that is just the action
memory and it will take the G factor
which is just the G we just calculated
now at the end of the episode once we
finish learning we want to reset the
agent's memory so that rewards from one
episode don't spill over into another
so there are two more functions we need
these are administrative we need a way
to load the checkpoint and we'll go
ahead and print out loading checkpoint
just so we know it's doing something and
then we have the saver object and we
want to restore a session from our
checkpoint file next we want to save a
checkpoint we're not gonna print here I
take it back
reason is that we're gonna be saving a
lot and I don't want it to print out a
bunch of junk statements so and what
these are doing is just either taking
the current graph as it is right now and
sticking it into a file or conversely
taking the graph out of the file loading
it into the graph for the current
session so that is that next we can move
on to the main program to actually test
our Lander so we'll need Jim and I
didn't I don't know if I made it clear
at the beginning but you'll also need
the box2d - PI environment so go ahead
and do a pip install box2d - pi if you
don't already have that
so we need to import our policy gradient
agent I have this plot learning function
I always use you can find it on my
github along with this code of course I
don't elaborate on it but basically what
it does is it takes a sequence of
rewards keeps track of it performs a
running average of say the last 20 25
whatever amount you want and spits that
out to a file we also have a way of
saving the renderings of the environment
so it runs much faster if you don't
actually render to the screen while it's
training but you can save those
renderings to files in mp4 files so you
can go back and watch them later
it's how I produce the episodes you saw
at the beginning of this video so first
thing you want to do is instantiate our
agent and we use a learning rate of zero
three zeros and a five and I believe all
all will need a gamma be something like
0.99 and all and then all the other
parameters will just leave at the
defaults next we need to make our
environment
and that's Lunar Lander v2 a way to keep
track of the scores the agent received
our initial score and number of episodes
so I achieved pretty good results after
2500 episodes so we can start with that
so the first thing we want to do is
iterate over our episodes oh let me do
this for you so before we do that I'll
comment this out but if you want to save
the output you do this
env Eagles rappers dot monitor passing
the environment wherever you want to
save it
lunar lander and then you want to use a
lambda function to tell it to render on
every episode and this force equals true
I believe that just tells it to
overwrite if there's already data in the
directory so at the top of every episode
just print out what episode number
you're on and the current score you set
you're done flag and for subsequent
episodes you'll want to reset the score
reset your environment into play and
episode first thing you want to do is
select an action
and that takes the observation as input
so we need to get the new observation
reward done flag and info by stepping
through the environment
once that's done you want to store the
transition set the old observation to be
the new one so that you select an action
based on the newest state and keep track
of the reward you received at the end of
every episode you want to append the
score to the score history and perform
our learning operation you also want to
save a checkpoint after every operation
ever after every learning operation and
then when you're done dictate some file
name dot PNG and call my super secret
plot learning function that just takes
the score history file name and a window
that tells it over how many games you
want to take the running average so now
let's go to our terminal and see how
many mistakes I made one second all
right so here we are let's go ahead and
give it a try so I made some kind of
error in the policy gradient agent let's
swing back to that file and see where it
is one second so here's the model it
does not have input dims that's because
I forgot to keep track of it
save go back to our terminal and see how
it does and I apparently called
something I should not have
this is line 27 says self thought label
placeholder got an unexpected keyword
argument named label ah that's because
it is called name that's what happens
when I try to type and talk at the same
time so let me make sure I didn't call L
one size L to size something different
no I did not all right I will run that
again so now it's unhappy about the
choice of oh of course
so it's looser there's no dash in there
get rid of that typos galore tonight oh
really oh really
ah it's store transitions yes so it's
actually store transitions so let's call
it that and there we go perfect so now
it's actually learning I'm not gonna sit
here and wait for this to do 2500 games
because I've already run this once
before that's how I got the code II saw
at the beginning so I'm gonna go ahead
and show you the plot that it produces
now so you can see how it actually
learns so by the end it gets up to about
an average reward of around 200 and
above points that's considered salt if
you check the documentation on the open
a item so congratulations we have solved
the lunar lander environment with the
policy gradient algorithm we relatively
simple just a say deep neural network
that calculates the probability of the
agent picking an action so I hope this
has been helpful go ahead and leave a
comment down below feel free to take
this code from my github for kit make it
better do whatever you want with it I
look forward to seeing you all in the
next video welcome back everybody to a
new reinforcement learning tutorial in
today's episode we're going to
to play space invaders using the policy
grading method let's get to it
we're imports we start with the usual
suspects numpy in tensorflow
we start by initializing our class for
the policy gradient agent we take the
learning rate discount factor number of
actions number of layers for the fully
connected layer the input shape channels
a directory for our checkpoints very
important as well as a parameter to
dictate which GPU we want tensorflow to
use if you only have one GPU or using
the CPU you don't need that parameter
save the relevant parameters and compute
the action space which is just a set of
integers we want to subtract out the
input Heights and width from the input
shapes and keep track of the number of
channels for use later
our agents memory will be comprised of
three lifts that keep track of the state
action and rewards we want a
configuration which just tells
tensorflow which GPU we want to use as
well as our accession graph that uses
that config we call the build Network
function and then use the TF global
variables initializer we need to keep
track of a saver and a checkpoint file
for saving and loading the model later
now if you don't know anything about
policy grading methods don't worry we're
gonna cover everything you need to know
as we go along the first thing we're
gonna need is a convolutional neural
network to handle image pre-processing
that'll be connected to a fully
connected layer that allows the agent to
estimate what action it wants to take in
contrast to things like deep Q learning
policy gradient methods don't actually
try to learn the action value or value
functions rather policy gratings try to
approximate the actual policy of the
agent let's take a look at that for our
build Network function we're going to
construct a convolutional neural network
with a few parameters an input
placeholder that has shaped a batch size
by input height and width as well as the
number of channels we will also need an
input for the labels which just
correspond to the actions the agent
takes that has shaped batch size and a
factor G which is just the discounted
future rewards following a given time
step
that has shaped back size our
convolutional neural network is going to
be pretty straightforward if you've seen
any of my videos you can kind of know
what to expect the first layer has 32
filters a kernel size of 8 by 8 and
astride of 4 and we're going to want to
use an initializer for this I found that
the Xavier initializer works quite well
the purpose of it is to keep the to
initialize all the parameters in such a
way that the they the network doesn't
have one layer with parameters is
significantly larger than any other we
want to do batch normalization I
mistyped the epsilon there should be one
by ten to the minus five and you want to
of course use a value activation on the
first convolutional layer in that
CommVault that activated output serves
as the input to the next layer with 64
filters kernel size of four by four and
astride of two and again we'll use the
Xavier initializer
of course we also want to do batch
normalization on this layer and at this
point I think I actually get the correct
epsilon for the batch normal and of
course we want to use a rel u activation
on that batch normed output as well
our third convolutional layer is more
the same 2d convolution with a hundred
twenty eight filters it will have a
kernel size of two by two a stride of
one and we'll also use the same
initialization again batch normalization
with an epsilon of 1 by 10 to the minus
5 activate with our Lu next we have to
take into account our fully connected
layers so the first thing we need to do
is flatten the output of the
convolutions because they come out as
matrices we need a list go ahead and
make the first fully connected layer
using FC one as the number of units ryu
activation and the second dense layer is
going to have units equal to the number
of actions for the agent which in this
case is just 6
notice that we don't activate that but
we have a separate variable for the
actions which is the activated output of
the network and we're gonna use a soft
Mac so that way we get two probabilities
that add up to one
need to calculate the negative log
probability with a sparse softmax
cross-entropy function with log it's
using dense to is our log 'its and
labels as the actions as our labels the
loss is just that quantity multiplied by
the expected feature rewards and of
course we want to reduce that quantity
now for the training operation we're
going to use the rmsprop optimizer with
a set of parameters
I found these to work quite well this
algorithm is pretty finicky so you may
have to play around the next thing we
have to do is code up the action
selection algorithm for the agent and
plessy gradient methods we're trying to
actually approximate the policy which
means we're trying to approximate the
distribution by which the agent chooses
actions given it's in some state s so
what we need is a way of computing those
probabilities and then sampling them
sampling the actions according to those
probabilities we choose an action by
taking in an observation reshaping it of
course this will be a sequence of frames
for hi and you want to calculate the
probabilities associated for each action
given that observation and then you want
to sample that probability distribution
using the numpy random choice function
next up we have to take care of the
agency so we're gonna store the
observation action and reward and the
agents lists using a simple append
function
so one big problem we're gonna have to
solve is the fact that policy gradient
methods are incredibly sample
inefficient these Monte Carlo methods
meaning that at the end of every episode
the agent is learning so it throws away
all of the experience it required in
Prior episodes so how do we deal with
that well one way to deal with that is
to actually queue up a batch of episodes
and learn based on that batch of
experiences the trouble here is that
when we take the rewards that follow any
given time step we don't want to account
for rewards following the current
episode so we don't want rewards from
one episode spilling over into another
so we have to take care of that here
next up we handle the learning for the
agent we want to we want to convert the
state action and reward memories into
arrays so that we can feed them into the
numbers use me tensorflow learning
function into these sorry the tensor
flow graph we have to start by reshaping
the state memory into something feasible
and then we can calculate the expected
feature rewards starting from any given
state so what we're gonna do is iterate
over the entire memory and take into
account the rewards the agent receives
for all subsequent time steps we also
need to make sure that we're not going
to take into account rewards from the
next episode next up we have to scale
the expected feature rewards this is to
reduce the variance in the problem so
this makes sure we don't have really
really large rewards so everything's
just kind of scaled next up we call the
training operation with an appropriate
feed dict of the state memory action
memory as labels and the G for our G
variable finally since we're done we're
going to clear out the agents memories
finally we just have some bookkeeping
functions to load and save checkpoints
you just call the saver restore function
that loads the checkpoint file into the
session and the save checkpoint just
dumps the current session into the
checkpoint file another problem we have
to solve is that the agent doesn't get a
sense of motion from only a single image
right if I show you a single image you
don't know if the aliens are moving left
or right or really you don't know which
direction you're moving so we have to
pass in a sequence of frames to get a
sense of motion for our agent this is
complicated by the fact that the open
anti Jim Atari library in particular
returns a set of frames that are
repeated so if you actually cycle
through the observations over time
you'll see that the frames change I
sorry don't change based on an interval
of one two or three so we had to capture
enough frames to account for that fact
as well as to get a overall sense of
movement so that means four is going to
be our magic number four so for stacking
frames next we move into the main
program we import Jim numpy our model as
well as the plot learning function which
is a simple utility you can find on my
github as well as the wrappers to record
the agents gameplay if you so choose we
need to pre-process the observation by
truncating it and taking the average
next up we stack the frames so at the
beginning of the episode the stack
frames will be none so you want to
initialize an empty array of zeros and
iterate over that array and set each of
those rows to be the current observation
otherwise what you want to do is you
want to pop off the bottom observation
shift everything down and put the fourth
spot or the last spot to be the current
observation down in the main function we
have a checkpoint flag if you want to
load a checkpoint we want to initialize
our agent with this set of hyper
parameters I found these to work
reasonably well you can play around with
them but it is incredibly finicky so
your mileage may vary we need a file
name to save our plots
we'll also want to see if we want to
load a checkpoint next we initialize our
environment space invaders of course
keep track of a score history score
number of episodes and our stack size of
4:1 iterate over the number of episodes
resetting the done flag at the top of
each episode we also want to keep track
of the running average score from the
previous 20 games just so we got an idea
if it's actually learning every 20 games
we're gonna print out the episode score
and average score otherwise every other
every other episode we're just going to
print out the episode number and the
score reset the environment and of
course you have to pre-process that
observation and then go ahead and set
your stack frames to none because we're
at the top of the episode and then call
the stack frames function so that we get
four of the initial observation so the
scored is zero and start iterating over
the episode so this first episode choose
an action based on that set of stack
frames go ahead and take that action and
get your new state action and reward go
ahead and pre process that observation
so that way you can stack it on the
stack of frames next up you have to take
care of the agent's memory by storing
that transition and finally you can't
increment your score or save the score
at the end of the episode and every 10
games are gonna handle learning and
saving a checkpoint and when you're all
done go ahead and plot the learning now
the agent is done we can take a look at
the actual plot it produces over time
this is how you know an agent is
actually learning what you'll see is
that there is some increase in the
average reward over time you'll see
oscillations up and down and that's
perfectly normal but what you want is an
overall upward trend now for this
particular set of algorithms it is
notoriously finicky with respect to
learning rates I didn't spend a huge
amount of time tuning them or playing
with them I just wanted to get something
good enough to show you guys how it
works and turn over to your capable
hands for fine tuning but what you do
see is a definite increase over time as
his average reward improves by about a
hundred points or so that isn't going to
win any awards but it is definitely at a
clear and unequivocal sign of learning
so there you have it
that was policy gratings in the Space
Invaders environment from the opening I
Jim I hope you learn something make sure
to check out this code on my github you
can fork it you can copy it you can do
whatever you want with it
make sure to subscribe leave a comment
down below if you found this helpful I
look forward to seeing you all in the
next video welcome back everybody to
neural net dot AI I am your host Phil
Taber
previously a subscriber asked me hey
Phil how do I create my own
reinforcement learning environment I
said well that's a great question I
don't have time to answer it in the
comments but I can make a video so here
we are what we're going to do in the
next two videos is create our own open
AI Jim compliant reinforcement learning
environment the grid world it's going to
be text-based and if you're not familiar
with it the grid world is aptly named a
grid of size M by n where the agent
starts out in say the top left and
that's to navigate its way all the way
to the bottom right the twist on this is
going to be that there will be two magic
squares that cause the agent to teleport
across the board the purpose of doing
this is to create a shortcut to see if
the agent can actually learn the
shortcut kind of interesting the agent
receives a reward a minus one with each
step except for the terminal step or
receives a reward of 0 therefore the
agent will attempt to maximize its
reward by minimizing the number of steps
it takes to get off the grid world what
other things to other concepts we need
are the concept of the state space which
is the set of all states - the terminal
state and the state space plus which is
e set of all states including the
terminal State this gives us a bit of a
handy way to find out the terminal state
as well as to find out if we're
attempting to make illegal moves it also
follows the nomenclature and terminology
from the Sutton Bardot book
reinforcement learning which is an
awesome resource you should definitely
check out if you have not already so in
part 1 we're gonna handle the
environment and in part 2 we're going to
get to the main loop and the agent for
which we will use cue learning not deep
cue learning because
this is a very straightforward
environment we don't need a functional
approximation we just need the tabular
representation of the agents estimates
of the action value function so if
you're not familiar with q-learning
I do have a couple videos on the topic
one where the q-learning agent solved
the card poll game as well as a an
explainer type video that talks about
what exactly q-learning
is so let's go ahead and get started
we only have a couple dependencies we're
not doing anything on the GPU so just
numpy and Matt plot line we want to
close everything up into a class called
grid world and our initializer will take
the M&N which is the shape of the grid
as well as the magic squares so we
represent our grid as an array of zeros
and shape and by n we want we want to
learn to type we want to learn to sorry
we can want to keep trying we want to
keep track of the M and the N for handy
use later so let's go ahead and define
our state space and that's just going to
be a list comprehension for all the
states in the range self dot M times
self dot n now the as I said the state
space does not include the terminal
state and the terminal state is the
bottom right so we have to go ahead and
remove or pop off that particular state
from the list
next up so now let's go ahead and again
learn to type go ahead and define our
state space plus also we need to know
the the way that the actions map up to
their change on the environment so we'll
call that the action space a little bit
of a misnomer but we can live with it
for now so moving up will translate the
agent up one row which is distance M and
moving down will advance the agents
position downward by also M moving the
left will translate the agent one step
will decrement the agents position by
one and moving right will increase it by
one we also want to keep track of the
set of possible actions you could use
the keys in the action space dictionary
but let's go ahead and use a separate
structure and we use a list up down left
and right the reason is that the
q-learning agent ik you learning
algorithm sorry can it can choose
actions at random so it's handy to have
a list from which you can choose
randomly next we need to add the magic
squares because that's a little bit more
complicated than it may seem and finally
when we initialize the grid we want to
set the agent to the top-left posy Shaun
let's go ahead and add those magic
squares
so of course you want to store that in
our object now there's a little bit of
HO keenest that I must explain so the
agent is represented by a zero when we
print out the grid to the terminal and
MD squares are represented by a one and
so excuse me and so that means we need
something other than zero and one to
represent these magic squares I want to
when I render the environment I want to
know where the entrance and where the
exit is
so we use different values for the
entrance and exit so that way we can
render it correctly
so just by royal decree we set I which
will be the representation of the of the
magic square in the grid world 2 2 to
start and I'm gonna go ahead and iterate
over the magic squares so now what we
need to know is what position we are in
so you sorry its if the color is off
indicating something is wrong I have
screwed something up royally which I do
not see because I am blind anyway so the
the exposition is just going to be the
floor of the current square and the
number of rows and Y will be the modulus
of the number of columns so then the
grid we want to set that x and y
position to I and since we want to have
a different representation for the
entrance and exits go ahead and set the
increment I by 1 recall that the magic
squares are is represented as a
dictionary so we're iterating over the
keys and the values are the destiny
Asians so the keys are the source values
our destinations so next we want to find
out precisely that what the destinations
are so that in and then set the grid
that Square to I and then increment hi
again and I'm only gonna do I'm only
going to do two magic squares you can do
any number but in this case we're just
gonna do two
so okay so the next thing we to know is
if we are in the terminal state and as I
said earlier the state space and state
space plus concepts give us a very easy
way of doing that so let's go ahead and
take care of that so since the state
space plus is all the states and the
states space is all the states - the
terminal state we know that the
difference between these two sets is the
terminal state so state in state space
plus and not in this state space how
does that look you scroll down a bit
okay so next up let us go ahead and get
the agent row and column
and we're going to use the same logic as
above so next we want to set the state
so that we'll take the new state as
input and we're going to go ahead and
assume that the new state is allowed so
the agent if it is along the left edge
and attempts to move left it just
receives a reward of minus one and
doesn't actually do anything
likewise if it's on the top row and
attempts to move up it doesn't actually
do anything it just gets a reward of
minus one for wasting its time so we
want to get sorry the row and column and
set that space to 0 because 0 denotes an
MB square and the agent position then is
the new state and again we want to get
the new X and new Y
there is a typo there let's fix that and
then set that position to 1 because that
is how we represent the agent by royal
decree so the next thing we have to know
is if we're attempting to move off the
grid that's not allowed
the agent can only stay on the grid so
let's take care of that so we want to
take the new and old States as input and
the first thing we wanna know is if
we're attempting to move off the grid
world entirely that's so I hate these
editors so if we are the new state is
not in the new state space plus we are
attempting to move off the grid so you
return true otherwise if the old state
modulus M equals 0 and new state modulus
this self dot M equals self dot M minus
1 then we return true and for brevity
and I could explain this but the video
is running long already so for brevity
the reason this is true is left as an
exercise to the reader bet you didn't
know this was gonna be like a college
course so now basically we're trying to
do here I'll just give you a hint what
we're trying to do here is determine if
we're trying to move off the grid either
to the left or to the right we don't
want to wrap around so so if you're for
instance if we have a 9 by 9 grid it
goes from 0 to 8 so then if you add 1
right
you would get 9 which would teleport you
to the other row and the 0th column you
don't want that what you want to do is
waste waste to move and receive a reward
of minus 1 so that's what we're doing
here
old state modulus good grief
so if neither of those are true then you
can go ahead and return false meaning
you're not trying to move off the grid
so let's see can you see that you can so
next function we need is a way to
actually step so let's go ahead and do
that let's say the only thing we need is
to take in the action so the first thing
you want to do is get the X&Y again and
here's where we're going to check to
make sure it's a legal move so the
resulting state is then agent position
plus the mapping so the agent position
is whatever it is and recall that the
action space is this dictionary here
that map's the actions to the
translations in the grid so we're doing
down here then is saying the new state
is equal to the current state plus
whatever the resulting translation is
for whatever action we're attempting to
make so next thing we need to know is
are we on a magic square and if we are
and if we are then the agent teleports
to its new position okay so next up we
need to handle the reward so it's minus
one if not is terminal state so it's
minus one if we haven't transitioned
into the terminal state otherwise it is
0 if we're not trying to move off the
grid
then we can go ahead and set that state
so if not set state salting state and
then we're ready to go ahead and return
so in the open the I Jim whenever you
take a step it returns the new state the
reward whether or not the game is over
and some debug information so we're
gonna do the same thing resulting state
reward and the whether or not it is the
terminal state and our debug info is
just going to be none so if we are
attempting to move off the grid what do
we want to do nothing so we want to
return agent position and the reward and
rather not it's terminal and the null
debug info we're almost there so next
thing we need to know is how do we reset
the grid because at the end of every
episode we have to reset right first
thing to do is set the agent position to
zero if you set the grid to zeros and go
ahead and add the magic squares back in
and return the agent position which is
of course zero oh wow that's real close
all right so next up one last function I
swear just one more I promise
all right I wouldn't lie to you all
right next up we want to provide a way
of rendering because hey that's helpful
for debug I like to print a whole big
string of you know dashes because it's
party we want to iterate over the grid
for column in row column equals zero in
other words if it's an empty square
we're just going to print a dash and
we're going to end it with a tab if the
column is one meaning we have an agent
there we're going to print an X to
denote the agent now if the column is
two then that is one of the entrances to
our magic squares so print the a in with
a tab delimited tab end if the column
equals three
you can print a alt and equals tab and
if the column equals 4 then we know
we're at the other magic square entrance
and finally if it's 5 then we know we're
at the other magic squares exit after
each row we want to print a new line and
at the end we'll go ahead and print
another chunk of pretty dashes oh yeah
that's it that is it okay so that is it
for our agent class that only took how
long 20-some minutes Wow okay I hope
you're still with me basic idea here is
to make your own environment you need
and initialize a reset a state space
state space plus a way to denote
possible actions a way to make sure the
move is legal and a way to actually
effect that environment the step
function needs to return the new
position the reward whether or not the
state is the new state is terminal as
well as some debug information you also
need a way of resetting and printing out
your environment to the terminal so in
part two we're actually gonna fire this
baby up with aq learning algorithm and
see how she do that's actually quite
exciting it moderately exciting anyway
it actually learns it does quite well
and it does find the magic square
spoiler alert if you made it this far it
finds a magic square and gets out of the
minimum number of moves required it's
pretty cool to see so that will come in
the next video on redness day I hope to
see you all then if you liked the video
make sure to leave a thumbs up subscribe
if you have not already for more
reinforcement learning content
and I will see you all in the next video
welcome back everybody to a new tutorial
from neural net a eye
I'm your host Phil Taber if you're new
to the channel I'm a physicist
former semiconductor process engineer
turned machine learning practitioner if
you haven't subscribed yet go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you don't
miss any future of reinforcement
learning tutorials when we left off in
our previous video we just finished up
the bulk of our opening IgM compliant
reinforcement learning environment today
we're going to go ahead and code up aq
learning agent and the main loop of the
program to see how it all performs so
let's go ahead and get started so the
first thing we are going to need is the
is the magic squares right
you recall the magic squares are the
teleporters in the grid world that
either advance the agent forward or
backward so the first one is going to be
at position 18 and dump out at position
54 so it'll move it forward and the next
one will be at let's say 63 and dump out
a position 14 so teleporter a will
advance the agent through the grid world
and teleporter B will send it back to an
earlier square so we need to create our
grid world we use a nine by nine grid
and pass in the magic squares we just
created next up we have to worry about
the model hyper parameters so if you are
not familiar with that let me give you a
quick rundown these are the parameters
that control how fast the agent learns
and how much it chooses to value the
potential future rewards so the first
parameter is alpha that is our learning
rate zero point one a gamma of one point
zero tells us that the agent is going to
be totally farsighted it will count all
future rewards equally an epsilon of one
point zero this is of course the epsilon
for Epsilon greedy action selection so
it will start out behaving pretty much
randomly and eventually converge on a
purely greedy strategy
so a Q learning is a tabular method
where you have a table of state in
action pairs and you want to find the
value of those state action pairs so to
construct that we have to iterate over
the set of states and actions state
space Plus and you have a doubt possible
actions and you have to pick something
for an initial value it's really
arbitrary but the cool thing about
picking 0 is that we're using something
called optimistic initial values well
this means is that since the agent takes
or receives a reward of minus 1 for
every step it can never have a reward of
0 right because there's some distance
between the agent and the exit so by
setting the initial estimate at 0 you
actually encourage exploration of
unexplored states because if the agent
takes a move it realizes oh I get a
reward of minus 1 that's significantly
worse than 0 let me try this other
unexplored option so over time and will
gradually explore all the available
actions for any given state because it's
been disappointed by all the stuff that
is previously tried just a fun little
fact we want to play 50,000 games we
need a way of keeping track of our
rewards numpy array will do just fine
yes so now let's iterate over the total
number of games and I like theif I like
to print out a marker to the terminal so
that way I know it's actually working so
every 5,000 games just print they were
starting
the eye thing at the top of every
episode you want to reset your done flag
you want to reset your episode rewards
so you don't accumulate rewards from
episode to episode and of course you
want to reset your environment oh let me
scroll down here here we go you want to
reset your environment just as you would
with any open agent type problem next up
we begin each episode so while not done
we want to take a random number for our
epsilon greedy action selection so we're
going to just make use of this max
action before we define it Q observation
and in V dot possible actions and what
that will do is we're gonna write it
here momentarily but what it's gonna do
is it is going to find the maximum
action for a given state so the random
number is less than 1 minus Epsilon we
want to do that can you guys see that
yep otherwise we want to take a random
sample of the action space so we have to
write these two functions let's do that
quite quickly so the
action space sample is pretty
straightforward we can just return a
random choice from the list of possible
actions and that's the reason we chose a
list as that data structure just to make
it easy next up we have the max action
max yeah max action function but that
doesn't need to belong to the class that
takes the cue the state and the set of
possible actions we want to take a numpy
array of the estimates agent sorry the
agents estimate of the present value of
the expected future rewards for the
stated stand in all possible actions a
in actions and then we want to find the
maximum of that and that's just an index
so we want sorry that's just an index so
we want to return the action that that
actually corresponds to all right that's
all well and good do we need more space
let's do a little bit more there we go
so next we want to actually take the
action so we get our new state
observation underscore reward done and
info yeah maybe that's step action and
next up we have to calculate the maximal
action for this new state so we can
insert that into our update equation for
the Q function so let's do that
and we're not worried about epsilon
greedy here because we're not actually
taking that action next up we have to
update our Q function for the current
action and state and that's where our
alpha comes in word plus make sure that
is visible to you reward plus some
quantity which is gamma our discount
factor times Q observation underscore
action underscore so the new state and
action - hue observation action let me
tab this over there we go nice and
complying to the pet style guides right
mostly okay
so this is the update equation for the Q
function that will update the agents
estimates of the value of the current
state and action pair next up we just
need to let the agent know that the
environment has changed states
so you set observation to observation
underscore and that is it for Q learning
in a nutshell folks that's really that
straightforward so the end of each
episode we want to decrease epsilon so
that way the agent eventually settles on
a purely greedy strategy you can do this
a number of ways you can do it you know
with a square root function a log
function I'm just gonna do it linearly
it's not that critical for something
like this
so it's going to decrease it by 2
divided by number every game so about
halfway through
it'll be purely greedy and at the end of
every episode you want to make sure
you're keeping track of the total
rewards which is something I forgot up
here yeah so one thing I did forget is
to keep track of the total reward for
the episode don't forget that very
important and at the end of all the
episodes you want to plot the total
rewards and that is it for the coding
portion oh one of the things I take it
back so let's scroll up here I do want
to show you the environment so let's
just do that and V dot render and the
purpose of doing that is so that you can
see how many moves it takes the agent to
escape from the grid world that will
tell us if it's doing good or not right
because there is animal number of moves
it takes to escape so I'm gonna fire up
the terminal and go ahead and get that
started one second and here we are in
the terminal let's go ahead and run that
and you can see here that we start at
the top left so it takes one to moving
to a out as free so three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven sorry eleven
and the twelfth move is free because
it's the exit to the maze
sorry through to the grid world so total
reward of minus 11 is the best the agent
can't possibly do it's gone ahead and
plotted so let's check that out and here
is the plot and you can see that indeed
the agent starts out rather poorly
exploring finding suboptimal routes
through the grid world but eventually
and about half way through here at 2500
or so sorry 25,000 you can see that it
settles on alisa constant
let's prove that it is the maximum value
of minus eleven and you can see that
it's ten point nine seven that is close
enough for government work so you see
that the agent is able to actually solve
the maze sorry the grid world I keep
calling it a maze it's able to solve the
grid world using the cube learning
algorithm now this isn't surprising you
know we would expect this
what's novel here is that we have
created our own reinforcement learning
environment that uses a very similar
format to the opening I gym so anytime
you want to create a new environment you
can use you can fire this video up and
use the you know set of code here just
as a template for your own projects I'm
gonna put this up on my github I'll link
that down below and I'm also gonna write
up a tutorial in text form and upload it
to neural net dot a I I don't know if
all that done tonight I'll update the
description with it and that's if you
are a you know if you consume text more
easily than that video then you can go
ahead and check that out I hope this has
been helpful make sure to leave a
comment subscribe if you haven't already
and I hope to see you all in the next
video
welcome back data manglers thanks for
tuning in for another episode from
neural net a I if you're new to the
channel I'm Phil Taber a physicist and
former semiconductor engineer turned
machine learning practitioner I'm on a
mission to teach the next generation of
data engineers so we can stay one step
ahead of our robot overlords you're not
subscribed be sure to do that now so you
don't miss any future reinforcement
learning content we've touched on
reinforcement learning many times here
on the channel as it represents our best
chance at developing something
approximating artificial general
intelligence we've covered everything
from Monte Carlo methods to deep Q
learning to policy gradient methods
using both the pine torch and tensor
flow frameworks what we haven't
discussed on this channel is the what
and the how of reinforcement learning
that oversight ends today right now
okay maybe a few seconds from now but
either way we're gonna cover the
essentials of reinforcement learning but
first let's take a quick step back
you're probably familiar with supervised
learning which has been successfully
applied to fields like computer vision
and linear regression here we need
mountains of data all classified by hand
just to train a neural network while
this has proven quite effective it has
some pretty significant limitations how
do you get the data how do you label it
these barriers put many of the most
interesting problems in the realm of
mega-corporations and this does us the
individual practitioners no good to top
it off it's not really intelligence you
and I don't have to see thousands of
examples of a thing to understand what
that thing is most of us aren't actively
by doing sure we can shortcut the
process by reading books or watching
youtube videos but ultimately we have to
get our hands dirty to learn if we
abstract out the important concepts here
we see that the essential stuff is the
environment that facilitates our
learning the actions that affected
environment and the thing that does the
learning the agent no jacket our labels
required enter reinforcement learning
this is our attempt to take those
ingredients and incorporate them into
artificial intelligence the environment
can be anything from text-based
environments like card games to classic
Atari games to real to the real world at
least if you're not afraid of Skynet
starting an all-out nuclear war that is
our AI interacts with this environment
through some set of actions which is
usually discrete move in some direction
or a fire at the enemy for instance
these actions in turn caused some
observable change in the environment
meaning the environment transitions from
one state to another so for example in
the space invaders environment in the
opening I Jim attempting to move left
cause the agent to move left with 100%
probability that need not be the case
though in the frozen lake environment
attempting to move left can result in
the agent moving right or up or down
even
so just keep it in mind that these state
transitions are probabilistic and their
probabilities don't have to be 100%
merely their sum the most important part
of the environment is the reward or
penalty the agent receives if you take
only one thing away from this video it
should be that the design of the reward
is the most critical component of
creating effective reinforcement
learning systems this is because all
reinforcement learning algorithms seek
to maximize the reward of the agent
nothing more nothing less
in fact this is where the real danger of
AI is it's not that it would be
malicious but that it would be
ruthlessly rational the classic example
is the case of an artificial general
intelligence his reward is centered
around how many paper clips it turns out
sounds innocent right well if you're a
paper clip making bot and you figure out
that humans consume a bunch of resources
that you need to make paper clips then
those pesky humans are in the way of an
orderly planetary scale office that's
problematic for all involved what this
means is we must think long and hard
about what we want to reward the agent
for and even introduce penalties for
undertaking actions that endanger human
safety Ellison systems that will see
action in the real world perhaps less
dramatic although no less important are
the implications for introducing
inefficiencies in your agent consider
the game of chess you might be tempted
to give the agent a penalty for losing
pieces but this would potentially
prevent the agent from discovering
gambits what sacrifices a piece for a
longer term positional advantage the
alpha 0 engine a chess-playing
artificial intelligence is notorious for
this and will sacrifice multiple ponds
and yet still dominate the best
traditional chess engines we have to
offer
so we have the reward the actions and
the environment what are the agent
itself the agent is the part of the
software that keeps track of these state
transitions actions and rewards and
looks for patterns to maximize its total
reward over time the algorithm that
it's how the agent will act in any given
situation or state of the environment is
called its policy it is expressed as a
probability of choosing some action a
given the environment is in some state s
please note these probabilities are not
the same as the state transition
probabilities the mathematical
relationship between the state
transitions rewards and the policy is
known as a bellman equation and it tells
us the value meaning the expected future
reward of a policy for some state of the
environment reinforcement learning often
though not always means maximizing or
solving that bellman equation more on
that in future videos this desire to
maximize reward leads to a dilemma
should the agent maximizes short-term
reward by exploiting the best known
action or should it be adventurous and
choose actions whose reward appears
smaller or maybe even unknown this is
known as the Explorer exploit a lemma
and one popular solution is to choose
the best known action most of the time
and occasionally choose a suboptimal
action to see if there's something
better out there this is called an
epsilon greedy policy when we think of
reinforcement learning
we're often thinking about the algorithm
the agent uses to solve the bellman
equation these generally fall into two
categories algorithms that require a
full model of their environment and not
rhythms that don't what does this mean
exactly to have a model of the
environment as I said earlier actions
caused the environment to transition
from one state to another with some
probability having a full model of the
environment means knowing all the state
transition probabilities with certainty
of course it's quite rare to know this
beforehand and so the algorithms that
require a full model are somewhat
limited utility this class of algorithms
is known as dynamic programming if we
don't have a model or a model of the
environment is incomplete we can't use
dynamic programming instead we have to
rely on the family of model free
algorithms one popular such algorithm is
Q learning or deep Q learning which you
studied on this channel
these rely on keeping track of the state
transitions actions
rewards to learn the model on the
environment over time in the case of
q-learning these parameters are saved in
a table and in the case of deep queue
learning the relationships between them
are expressed as an approximate
functional relationship we just learned
by a deep neural network that's really
all there is at least at a high level so
to recap reinforcement learning is a
class of machine learning algorithms
that help an autonomous agent navigate a
complex environment the agent must be
given a sequence of rewards or penalties
to learn what is required of it the
agent attempts to maximize this reward
over time or in mathematical terms to
solve the bellman equation the
algorithms that help the agent estimate
future rewards fall into two classes
those that require we know the state
transition probabilities for the
environment beforehand and those that
don't
since knowing these probabilities is a
rare luxury we often rely on model free
algorithms like deep Q learning you'd
like to know more please check out some
of the other videos on this channel I
hope this has been helpful please leave
a comment I like and subscribe if you
haven't already
I look forward to seeing you all in the
next video welcome back did the free
reinforcement learning course from
neural net dot AI I'm your host Phil
Taber if you're not subscribed be sure
to do that now and hit the bell icon so
you get notified for each new module in
the course in module one we covered some
essential concepts in reinforcement
learning
so if you haven't seen it go ahead and
check it out now so this module makes
more sense if you have seen it you may
remember that reinforcement learning
basically boils down to an agent
interacting with some environment and
receiving some rewards in the process
these rewards tell the agent what's good
and bad and the agent uses some
algorithm to try to maximize rewards
over time in practice what we get is a
sequence of decisions by the agent and
each decision doesn't just influence its
immediate reward rather each decision
influences all future rewards
in mathematical terms we have a sequence
of states actions and rewards that one
could call a decision process if each
state in this process is purely a
function of the previous state and
action of the agent then this process is
called a Markov decision process our MDP
for short
these are an idealized mathematical
abstraction that we use to construct the
theory of reinforcement learning from
any problems this assumption can be
broken to various degrees how much that
really matters is often a complicated
question and one we're just going to
dodge for now regardless in most cases
the assumption that a process obeys the
Markov property is good enough and we
can use all the resulting mathematics
for reinforcement learning problems by
now I've said that a reinforcement
learning agent seeks to maximize rewards
over time so how does this fit into a
Markov decision process from the agent's
perspective it receives some sequence of
rewards over time and as sequence of
rewards can be used to construct the
expected return for the agent then the
return at some time step T is just the
sum of the rewards that follow all the
way up to some final time capital T this
final time step
naturally introduces the concept of
episodes which are discrete periods of
gameplay that are characterized by state
transitions actions and rewards upon
taking this final time step the agent
enters some terminal state which is
unique this means that no matter how we
end the episode the terminal state is
always the same no future rewards follow
after we reach the terminal state so the
agents expected reward for that terminal
state is precisely 0 with a bit of
creativity we call tasks that can be
broken into episodes
episodic tasks of course not all tasks
are episodic many are in fact continuous
this is a bit of a problem since if the
final time step is at infinity the total
reward could also be infinite this makes
the concept of maximizing rewards
meaningless so we have to introduce an
additional concept the fix and
for both episodic and continuing tasks
is the idea of discounting this
basically means the agent values future
rewards less and less this discounting
follows a power law where each time step
results and more and more discounting
this hyper parameter gamma is called the
discount rate and even no doubt seen
this before in our videos on
reinforcement learning if you use this
form for the expected return and do some
simple factoring you derive a really
useful fact there is a recursive
relationship between rewards at
subsequent time steps this is something
we'll exploit constantly in
reinforcement learning so we have an
agent that is engaged in some discrete
processes receiving rewards and trying
to maximize its expected feature returns
if you remember from the first lecture
the algorithm that determines how the
agent is going to act is called its
policy since the agent has a set of
defined rules for how its going to act
in any given state it can use a sequence
of states actions and rewards to figure
out the value of any given state the
value of a state is the expected return
when starting in that state and
following the policy it's given formally
by the following equation in some
problems like say Q learning we're more
concerned with maximizing the action
value function which tells the agent the
value of taking some action while in
some given State and following the
policy they're after remember how I said
we can exploit the recursive
relationship between subsequent returns
well if you plug that into the
expression for the value function we
actually discover that the value
function itself is defined recursively
this is called the bellman equation from
the first module and this is the
quantity many algorithms seek to
maximize the bellman equation is really
an expectation value as it's a weighted
average of how likely each particular
sequence of states actions and rewards
is given the state transition
probabilities and the probability of the
agents selecting that action much of the
following material will involve coming
up with various schemes to solve the
bellman equation and evolve the policy
and
such a way that the value function
increases over time in the next module
we'll take a look at the explore exploit
dilemma which is the expression of the
trade-off between long and short term
rewards I hope this has been helpful
questions comments suggestions leave
them below I read and answer all my
comments if you made it this far
consider subscribing so you get notified
in the rest of the course drops I look
forward to seeing you in the next video
welcome to module three of the free
reinforcement learning course from
neural net dot AI I'm your host Phil
Taber if you're not subscribed make sure
to do that now so you don't miss the
rest of the course in the previous video
we learned about a special type of
process called the Markov decision
process there each state depends only on
the previous state and the action taken
by the agent this leads to the recursive
relationship between the agents estimate
of returns at successive time steps this
relationship extends to the agents
estimate of the value function which is
given by the bellman equation as we
covered in module 1 reinforcement
learning for the most part boils down to
maximizing this value function however
it's not always so simple surprise
surprise just like you and I have trade
offs in real life reinforcement learning
agents are faced with similar
considerations to the agent take the
action that it knows will immediately
provide the most reward or should it
explore other actions to see if it can
do better this conundrum is known as the
Explorer exploit dilemma and every
reinforcement learning algorithm has to
deal with this fortunately there are
many solutions and we'll cover some of
them here one such solution is the idea
of optimistic initial values when the
agent starts playing the game it has to
use some initial estimate for the value
or action value function this estimate
is totally arbitrary but if we know
something about the reward structure
beforehand we can actually initialize it
in such a way as to encourage
exploration
suppose we have an environment like our
grid world in the video on creating our
own reinforcement learning environment
in that environment the agent receives a
reward of minus one for each step and so
the expected returns are always negative
or zero no matter of the state of the
environment or the action the agent
takes so what would happen if we tell
the agent that the value of all the
state action pairs are positive or even
zero on the first move the agent picks
some action randomly because all the
actions all look identical it receives a
reward of minus one and updates his
estimates accordingly so it's a bit
disappointed it was expecting chocolate
cake and got a mud pie the next time it
encounters that state it will take a
different action because the other
actions have an estimate of zero reward
for that state which is better than the
negative reward it actually received
this means that the agent ends up
exploring all the state action pairs
many times as each update makes the
agents estimate more and more accurate
we never had to explicitly tell the
agent to take exploratory actions
because it's greed drove it to take
exploratory actions after it became
disappointed with whatever action it
just took again this is called
optimistic initial values another
feasible solution is to spend some
portion of the time choosing random
actions and the majority of the time
choosing greedy actions this is called
an epsilon greedy strategy and it's the
one we employ the most it's quite robust
as we can change the random parameter
over time so that the agent converges on
to a nearly pure greedy strategy the
proportion of the time the agent spends
exploring is a hyper parameter of the
problem and we typically call it epsilon
one potential strategy is to start out
completely randomly and then use some
decay function to gradually increase the
proportion of ridi actions the agent
takes the form of this function isn't
critically important it can be linear a
power law or really any other function
whether or not the agent converges to a
purely greedy strategy is going to
depend on the problem for simple
environments like the grid world where
we know the optimal solution beforehand
it makes quite a bit of sense converged
to a purely greedy strategy
however with a game like space invaders
a popular environment from the open AI
Jim there are so many variables that
it's hard to be sure the agent has
settled on the truly optimal strategy
the solution there is to leave Epsilon
it's so small but finite value so the
Asian is occasionally taking exploratory
actions to test its understanding of the
environment all of this discussion has
made a very important assumption we've
assumed the agent only uses a single
policy the agent uses both the same
policy to update this estimate of the
value function as well as to generate
actions there's no rule this has to be
the case in fact an agent can leverage
two policies it can use one policy to
generate actions and then use the data
that generates to update the value
function for some other policy this is
called off policy learning and this is
precisely what we use in Q learning the
agent uses some epsilon greedy strategy
to generate steps in the Markov chain
which is the sequence of state action
rewards and resulting states and then
uses that data to update the estimate of
the action value function for the purely
greedy action in effect we're using an
epsilon greedy strategy to update our
estimate of the purely greedy strategy
let's just say this works quite well and
it's something we'll come back to in
later modules when we get to Monte Carlo
methods and temporal difference learning
that's it for now reinforcement learning
agents seek to maximize their total
reward but face a dilemma and whether to
maximize current reward or take
exploratory steps with suboptimal
actions in the hope of optimizing long
term rewards one solution is to bias the
agents at initial estimates in such a
way that it encourages exploration
before settling on a purely greedy
strategy
another is suspense on proportion of the
time exploring and the majority of the
time exploiting the best known action
and finally the agent can leverage two
policies want to generate data and the
other to update the estimate of the
action value or value function in the
next module we're going to get to
dynamic programming class of model-based
reinforcement learning algorithms make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss the
room
of this course and I look forward to
seeing you in the next video welcome
back everybody to machine learning with
Phil I am your host dr. Phil when we
last touched on the opening idea we did
Q learning to teach the cart pole robot
how to dance basically how to balance
the pole in this video we're gonna take
a look at a related algorithm called
salsa so they're related in the sense
that they're both types of temporal
difference learning algorithms the
difference being that salsa is an on
policy method and q-learning is an off
policy method hey parents by the cat if
you if you don't know what that means I
highly encourage you to check out my
course reinforcement learning in motion
on Manning publications I go in-depth on
all this stuff in that course enough
plugging let's get back to it so the
other cool thing is that it that sarsa
as well as key learning are model free
meaning that you do not need a complete
model of your environment to actually
get some learning done and that's
important because there's many cases in
which you don't know the full model of
the environment what does that mean it
means you don't know the state
transition probabilities so if you're in
some state s and take some action a what
is the probability will end up in state
s prime and get reward are those
probabilities are not completely known
for all problems and so algorithms that
handle that uncertainty are critical for
real-world applications another neat
thing is that this is a bootstrap method
meaning that it uses estimates to
generate other estimates right so you
don't need to know too much about the
system to get started you just make some
wild-ass guesses and you get moving
let's take a look at the algorithm so
your first step is to initialize your
learning rate alpha and of course that's
going to control the rate of learning
how do you make adjustments to the Q
function then you initialize the Q
function the hue function is just the
agents estimate of its discounted future
rewards starting from a given state s
and taking an action a and it may have
some assumptions built in onto whether
or not you follow some particular policy
or not but that's the general gist so
you need to initialize your state and
choose some initial action based on that
state using an epsilon greedy strategy
from that function queue any loop over
the episode taking the action getting
your reward and your new state s prime
choose an action a prime as a function
of that state s prime using epsilon
greedy from your Q function and then go
ahead and update the Q function
according to the update rule you see on
the screen and then go ahead and store
your state prime into s and your a prime
into a and loop until the episode is
done again in the course I go into many
more details this is just quick and
dirty a bit of a teaser video to get you
guys interested in the course and to
give you some useful information at the
same time so with that being said let's
go ahead and jump into the code I'm not
gonna be doing typing on-screen but I
will be showing you the relevant code as
we go along and boom we are back in the
code editor so here I am using Visual
Studio code even on Linux this is a
great editor if you're not using it I
highly recommend it Adams a little bit
buggy for me and of course sublime is
now is nag where so go ahead and give it
a look if you haven't already so we
needed to find a function to take the
max action and that takes as inputs the
Q function as well as the state and
you're just converting the the Q
function into an array and to a numpy
array free to action and that in that
list and finding the Arg max of that now
recall that in numpy the Arg max takes
the returns the first element of a max
so if you have two actions that are tied
it'll give you the first one so of
course in the carpol example our action
space is just moving left and right
right if you don't remember it's just a
cart and slides along the x axis trying
to keep a pole vertical of course this
is a continuous space and the Q function
is a discrete a discrete mathematical
construct right so the states are
discrete numbers and so you have to do a
little trick here to discretize your
space and so if you look in the
documentation for the cart poll example
you'll find the limits on these
variables and you can use that to create
a linear space based out of it based on
those limits and divide it up into ten
different buckets right so that way you
get you go from a continuous
representation to a discrete
representation of your state space and
then I define a small helper function
to get the States based on the
observation it just digitizes these it
digitizes those linear spaces using the
observation that you pass in from the
open antigen and it returns a four
vector that is a the buckets that
correspond to the value of the element
of the observation in the main program
we want to use a small learning rate
alpha 0.1 for a gamma something like 0.9
of course the gamma is the discount
factor it's debatable whether or not you
need it here so discounting in general
is used when you don't know the we you
don't know for a certain you're gonna
get some reward in the future so it
doesn't make sense to give it a hundred
percent weight you could just as easily
here use a one point zero because the
state-transition functions in the car
pool example are deterministic as far as
I'm aware some if I'm wrong please
someone correct me and of course the
epsilon for the epsilon greedy we're
going to start out at one point zero
you'll see why here in a second and so
you need to construct the set of states
which of course just corresponds to the
integer representations of our
continuous space so you just have ranges
from zero to zero to nine and you
construct a four vector out of out of
that right so you have 0 0 0 1 1 1 etc
etc etc and initialize your Q function
here I'm going to initialize everything
as a zero right recall that we had to we
could initialize it arbitrarily but for
the terminal States you want that to be
zero because again the value of the
terminal state is 0 and a is 2 in the
range of 2 because we only have two
actions move left move right oops also
I'm gonna run 50,000 games if you have a
slower computer you might want to run
fewer it takes quite a bit of time to
run and I'm gonna track the total
rewards as we go along so just a little
helper line here to print out the the
number of games you're playing that's
always good to know where you are right
you if it stops chugging along you want
to know if it's broken or back they
doing something useful
so you get your initial observation by
resetting the environment get your state
and calculate a random number and so you
take a maximum action if the random
number is less than 1 minus epsilon so
epsilon is starting out at 1 so if
random is less than 0 otherwise randomly
sample your action space done flag to
false and your rewards for the episode
to 0 then you loop over the episode
until you're done and you go ahead and
take the action a getting your reward
and the new observation the state prime
then is going to be the get State of the
observation right these observation is a
four-vector of continuous numbers that
we had to transform into a set of
discrete integers for vector of discrete
integers then we go ahead and calculate
another random number and choose another
action based upon that and calculate sum
up the total rewards and update the q
function based on the update rule I gave
you in the slides and of course set the
state in action to the new the S Prime
and a prime and after each episode
you're going to decrease epsilon because
you want this you don't want the epsilon
to be permanently 1 right you want to
encourage some amount of exploration and
some amount of exploitation so epsilon
has to be a function of time and just
save your total rewards when it's all
done its gonna go ahead and plot it out
and you should see something similar to
the following I'm going to go ahead and
run that now and that is going to take a
minute to run and so here you have the
output of the source of algorithm after
running 50,000 iterations so what you
see is first of all the messy plot
that's to be expected with 50,000 games
and you're plotting every single point
but what you've noticed immediately is
that there's a general trend upward and
when epsilon reaches its minimum epsilon
goes to 0 and it does a fully
exploitative strategy the algorithm
actually does a really good job of
hitting 200 moves most of the time
recall that 200 moves is the 200 moves
is the maximum number of steps for the
carpool problem because good algorithms
can get it to balance
pretty much indefinitely so I would
never terminate so the open a gym just
terminates at 200 steps so anything
close to that is pretty good now one
thing that's interesting is that it does
have a fair amount of variability it
doesn't actually balance it 200 moves
the entire time and there are a number
of reasons for this perhaps you can
speculate below I invite you to
speculate my thought process is that the
the way we have discretized in this
space isn't sufficient to characterize
the problem in such a way that the
algorithm can learn something completely
and totally useful so it just doesn't
have enough information based on the ten
thousand ten to the four yeah ten
thousand states we've we've discretized
it into and there could be other things
that matter you know you could have
other features for instance combinations
of velocities and positions that matter
so we could have under engineered the
problem slightly but for just a quick
little chunk of 170 lines of code or so
it's actually quite good so any
questions you should be sure to leave
them below and hey if you've made it
this far and you haven't subscribed
please consider i'm gonna be releasing
more and more content like this and do
this full time now and i look forward to
seeing you all in the next video
oh and by the way in the next video
we're gonna be taking a look at double
q-- learning which is yet another
variation of these model free bootstrap
methods see you then oh and one other
thing if you want the code for this I'll
leave the code I'll leave the link to my
github now this is code for my course
reinforcement learning in motion I'm
just showcasing it here to show what
you're gonna learn in the course so go
ahead and click the link in the
description and it'll take you to my
github where you can find that code as
well as all the code from the course
hope you like it
see you guys in the next video welcome
back everybody to machine learning with
Phil I am your host dr. Phil in
yesterday's video we took a look at
salsa in the opening I June getting the
cart pole to balance itself as promised
today we are looking at the algorithm of
double Q learning also in the cart pole
opening IgM environment so we touched on
Q learning many many months ago and the
basic idea is that Q learning is a
model-free bootstrapped of policy
learning algorithm what that means is
model free it does not need to know it
does not need the complete state
transition dynamics of the environment
to function it learns the game by
playing it bootstrapped in that it
doesn't need very many very much help
getting started it generates estimates
using its initial estimates which are
totally arbitrary except for the
terminal states off policy meaning that
it is using a separate policy other than
it is using a behavior policy and the
target policy to both learn about the
environment and generate behavior
respectively
now when you deal with problems that
when you deal with algorithms that take
a maximizing approach to choosing
actions you always get something called
maximization bias so say you have some
set of states with many different
actions such that the action value
function for that states and all actions
is zero then the agents estimate the Q
capital Q of SN a can actually be well
actually have some uncertainty to it and
that uncertainty is actually a spread in
the values right and that spread causes
it to have some amount of positive bias
and the max of the true values is 0 but
the max of the capital Q the agents
estimate is positive hence you have a
positive bias and that can often be a
problem in in reinforcement learning
algorithms so this happens because
you're using the same set of samples to
max to determine the maximizing action
as well as the value of that action and
one way to solve this problem is to use
two separate q functions to determine
the max action and the value and you set
up a relationship between them and then
you alternate between them as you play
the game so you're using one of them to
determine the max action one of them to
determine its value and you alternate
between them so that you eliminate the
bias over time that's double Q learning
in a nutshell the algorithm is the
following so you initialize your alpha
and your epsilon where alpha is your
learning rate epsilon is what you use
for epsilon greedy you would initialize
the Q 1 and Q 2 functions for all states
and actions in your state and action
space of course that's arbitrary except
for the terminal States we must have a
value of 0 and you loop over your set of
episodes and you initialize your state
and for each episode right each step
within the episode choose an action from
using
your state using Epsilon greedy strategy
in the sum of q1 and q2 so you have the
two separate queue functions so if
you're using single queue learning you
would take the max action over just one
queue but since you're dealing with two
you have to account for that somehow
right you could do a max you could do a
sum you could do an average in this case
we're gonna take the sum of the two
queue functions take that option get
your reward observe the news state and
then with the 0.5 probability either
update q1 or q2 according to this update
rule here and of course at the end of
the step go ahead and set your estate to
the new state and keep looping until the
game is done so clear as mud I hope so
by the way if you want more
reinforcement learning content make sure
to subscribe hit the bell icon so you
get notified let's get to it so next up
we have our code and here we are inside
of our code editor again am using Visual
Studio code to take a look at our double
Q learning script I'm not gonna be
typing into the terminal I think that's
probably a little bit annoying I'm just
gonna review the code as we go along
if you have seen my video on the Saros
an algorithm there's gonna be a fair
amount of overlap because we're solving
the same set of problems over again the
only real difference is in that video we
just saw so to calculate the action
value function and in this case we're
using double Q learning again we have a
max action function well this does is
tells us the max action for a given
state to construct that you make a numpy
array out of a list that is for a given
state in both actions and as we said in
the video we're gonna take the sum of
the q1 and q2 for a given state for both
actions you want to take the arc max of
that and recall in numpy the Arg max
function if there is a tie returns the
first element so if the left and right
actions both have identical action value
functions then it will return the left
action consistently that may or may not
be a problem it's just something to be
aware of and once again we have to
discretize the spaces recall that the
carpool problem which is just the cart
sliding along a track with a pole that
is that must be maintained vertically
right and the cart pole example we have
a continuous space the X and
theta can be any number within a given
range and likewise for the velocities to
deal with that we have a couple options
we could simply use neural networks to
approximate those functions but in this
case we're going to use a little trick
to discretize the space so we're going
to divide it up into ten equal chunks
and any number that falls within a
particular chunk will be assigned an
integer so you'll go from a continuous
to a discrete representation of your for
vector the observation along with that
comes a get state observing state along
that comes a get state function that you
pass in the observation and it just uses
those digitized spaces excuse me just
uses those linear spaces to use the
numpy digitize function to get the
integer representation of the respective
elements of your observation I've also
added a function to plot the running
average here I do this because in this R
sub video we ended up with a little bit
of a mess with fifty thousand data
points this will plot a running average
over the prior 100 games next up we have
to initialize our hyper parameters our
learning rate of 0.1 this just controls
the step size in the update equation the
gamma is of course the discount factor
the agent uses in its estimates of the
future rewards so I don't believe this
should actually be 0.9 IU I left it here
because it's not super critical as far
as I'm concerned it should really be 1.0
and the reason is that the purpose of
discounting is to account for
uncertainties in future rewards if you
have some sequence of rewards with a
probability of receiving them then it
makes no sense to give each of those
rewards equal weight because you don't
know if you're going to get them in the
cart poll example the rewards are
certain as far as I'm aware of the state
transition probabilities are one you
know that if you move right you're gonna
actually end up moving right you know
deterministically where the poll and the
cart are going to move so it shouldn't
be discounted as far as I'm concerned
epsilon is just the epsilon factor for
our for our epsilon greedy algorithm and
that's pretty much it for hyper
parameters of the model next up we had
to construct our state space so what
this means
Oh baby's unhappy the state space is of
course the the representation of the
digitized space so we're gonna have for
the cart position you're gonna have ten
buckets the velocities ten buckets and
likewise for the thetas thetas position
and theta velocity so you're gonna have
ten to the four possible states so ten
thousand states and those are gonna be
numbered all the way from 0 0 0 to 9999
that's all we're doing here is we're
constructing the set of states next up
we have to initialize our Q functions
recall that the initialization is
arbitrary except for the terminal state
which must have a value of 0 the reason
for this is that the terminal state by
definition has a future value of 0
because you stop playing the game right
makes sense
you could initialize this randomly you
could initialize it with minus 1 plus 1
doesn't really matter so long as the
terminal state is 0 for simplicity I'm
initializing everything at 0 I'm gonna
play a hundred thousand games the reason
is that this algorithm eliminates bias
but at the expense of convergent speed
so you have to let it run a little bit
longer an array for keeping track of the
total rewards and we're gonna loop over
a hundred thousand games printing out
every 5,000 games to let us know it's
still running I always want to reset
you're done flying your rewards and
reset the episode at the top and you're
gonna loop over the episode getting your
state calculating a random number for
your epsilon greedy strategy you're
gonna set the action to be the max
action of Q 1 and Q 2 if the random
number is less than 1 minus epsilon
otherwise you're gonna randomly sample
your action space in any event you take
that action get your new state reward
and done flag and go ahead and tally up
your reward and convert that observation
to a state s prime then go ahead and
calculate a separate random number the
purpose of this random number is to
determine which q function we're going
to update you know we're gonna be using
one to calculate we're alternating
between them because we have to
eliminate the maximization bias right
one is for finding the max action one is
for finding the value of that action we
alternate between episodes by way of
this rain
number in both cases you want to collect
the you want to calculate the max action
either q1 or q2 and use the update rule
I showed you in the slides to update the
estimates for q1 and q2 as you go at the
end of the episode sorry at the end of
the step excuse me you want to reset the
old observation to the new one
so that way you can get the state up
here and at the end of the episode you
want to go ahead and decrease Epsilon if
you're not familiar with this epsilon
greedy is just a strategy for dealing
with the explore exploit dilemma so an
agent always has some estimate of the
future rewards based on this model the
environment or its experience playing
the game if it's model free or a model
of problem right it can either explore
or exploit its best known action so one
way of dealing with the dilemma of how
much time should you spend exploring
versus how much time should you spend
exploiting is to use something called
epsilon greedy meaning that some
percentage of time you explore or some
percentage of the time you exploit and
the way that you get it to settle on a
greedy strategy is to gradually decrease
that exploration parameter epsilon over
time and that's what we're doing here
and of course you want to keep track of
the total rewards for that episode and
recall in the carpol example the agent
gets a reward of positive 1 every time
the pole stays vertical and so every
move that it doesn't flop over it gets
one point and at the end you're gonna go
ahead and plot your running averages so
I'm gonna go ahead and run that and
that'll take a minute while it's running
I want to ask you guys a question so
what type of material do you want to see
from what I'm seeing in the data the the
reinforcement learning stuff is
immensely popular my other content not
so much so I'm going to keep focusing on
this type of stuff but are you happy
seeing the Sutton and Bardot type
introductory material or do you want to
see more deep learning type material
right there's a whole host of dozens of
deep reinforcement learning algorithms
we can cover but I'm actually quite
content to cover this stuff because I
believe that if you can't master the
basics then the deep learning stuff
isn't going to make sense anyway right
because you have the complexity of deep
learning on top of the complexity of the
reinforcement learning material
on top of it so if there's anything a
particularly you guys want to see make
sure to leave a comment below
and hey if you haven't subscribed and
you happen to like reinforcement
learning in machine learning material
please consider doing so if you liked
the video make sure to leave a thumbs up
if you thought it sucked go ahead and
leave a thumbs down and tell me why I'm
happy to answer the comments hence your
objections and if you guys have
suggestions for improvement I'm all ears
and here we are it is finally finished
with all hundred thousand episodes and
you can see here the running average
over the course of those games as you
would expect the agent begins to learn
fairly quickly balancing the cart pull
more and more and more by about sixty
thousand games it starts to hit thee
consistently hit the 200 move threshold
where it is able to balance the cart
pull all 200 moves of the game now
recall this was with a gamma of 1.0 I'm
going to go ahead and rerun this with a
gamma of 0.9 and see how it does so burn
this image into your brain and I'm gonna
go ahead and check it out with a gamma
of 0.9 and see if we can do any better
then we are back with the second run
using a gamma of 0.9 and you can see
something quite interesting here so it
actually only kind of ever reaches the
200 mark just for a handful of games and
then kind of stutters along actually
decreasing in performance as it goes
along
so something funny is going on here and
to be frank I off the top of my head and
not entirely certain why so I invite you
all to speculate however the what's also
interesting is that I this is the second
time of recording this I recorded it
earlier and didn't scroll down the code
so you ended up staring at the same
chunk of stuff had to redo it and in
that case I had a gamma is 0.9 as well
and it seemed to work just fine so I
suspect there's some significant
variation here to do with the random
number generator and I could just all be
do to that right this is a complex space
and it wanders around different portions
this could happen potentially because it
doesn't visit all areas of the parameter
space enough times to get a reasonable
estimate of the samples and there may be
some type of bias on where it visits
later on in the course of the episodes
although that sounds kind of unlike
to me but either way that is double
q-learning you can see how the hyper
parameters actually affect the model and
it seems to have a fairly large effect
as you might expect and the next video
we're gonna be taking a look at double
sarsa so if you are not subscribed I ask
you to please consider doing so hit the
notification icon so you can see when I
release a video and look forward to
seeing you all in the next video well I
hope that was helpful everyone so what
did we learn we learned about Q learning
policy gradient methods sarsa double Q
learning and even how to create our own
reinforcement learning environments this
is a very solid foundation in the topic
of reinforcement learning and then
you're pretty well prepared to go out
and explore more advanced topics so what
are those more advanced topics so right
now the forefront are things like deep
deterministic policy gradients which is
as you might guess from the name a more
advanced version of policy gradient
methods they're also actor critic
methods behavioural cloning there's all
sorts of more advanced topics out there
that you're now pretty well-equipped to
go explore these are particularly useful
in environments where you have
continuous action spaces so all the
environments we studied in this set of
tutorials have a discrete action space
meaning the agent only moves or takes
some discrete set of actions other
environments such as the bipedal Walker
car racing things of that nature have
continuous state spaces so excuse me a
continuous action spaces which require
different mechanisms to solve Q learning
really can't handle it so you're now
free to go ahead and check that stuff
out if you made it this far please
consider subscribing to my channel
machine learning with phil and i hope
this is helpful all of you leave a
comment down below and make sure to
share this and i'll see you all in the
next video